hey everyone jessica from codercoder
here
thanks so much to free codecamp for
having me on their channel
in this video we're going to build a
landing page template from
frontendmentor.io
if you get stuck at any time during this
tutorial you can check out the completed
source code on my github
link down below and if you like this
video and want more i'm actually
creating a course
called responsive design for beginners
you can sign up to get updates on my
progress creating the course as well as
be the first to find out when it
launches
and without further ado let's get into
it
all right so the website we're going to
be building today is from front end
mentor dot io
they have tons of different challenges
of website templates you can build
yourself
and the one we're building today is
called easy bank landing page
now what i'm going to do is download
these starter free files
and with that you just get jpegs of the
design
which you can definitely work off of but
if you want the full sketch file you
have to pay 8.99 so either way works
we're going to be working with the free
files right now
so let's set up our project on the left
i have my empty project folder
and then on the right we have the files
that we downloaded from front end mentor
in this folder i have an index.html file
which we do want to carry over here to
our project
there's also an images folder and these
contain the svgs and pngs and jpegs
that we need to use for this website so
we're going to copy the images folder
over
as well and there's also a style guide
file which i think would be pretty handy
and then lastly
the design folder contains the jpegs of
the different designs
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
show you
i've made an adobe xd file and in that
i've basically
copied and pasted all the jpegs so that
i have all the designs in one place
just makes things a little bit easier so
now that we have our files in our
project
let's open up vs code
okay so here in vs code i have the
project folder open
you can see that we have the index.html
file from frontimentor
and we also have the style guide file
which is helpful to tell you
you know what what's the designs at as
well as some colors and
font information so we'll definitely be
using those and we have the images
folder here with all the images
okay so when i'm working with website
projects usually i'm going to be using
sas
scss syntax and we're going to have to
also have some javascript so let's
create those files now
so in the project root i'm going to
create a folder called app
in that folder i'm going to create two
sub folders one for js
for the javascript file and one for scss
for our sas files
so in the sas file folder in the sas
folder rather
let's create our main sas file
style.scss
and this is going to be the main sas
file that we're going to import all of
our partial sas files into
and we're going to create one called
globals
scss yeah that's right i also usually
create one called
variables because i like using sas
variables a lot
so let's import those into our main sas
file
import variables because we want our
variables to come first so the other sas
files can use them
then import globals okay
so let's start adding some boilerplate
styles here so the global the first one
i usually do is
in the html selector i'm going to say
font size is 100
this is more accessible lets the user
control the
zoom level in their browser we're also
going to do box sizing
border box and what this property does
is it makes the
size of elements sort of include padding
in the final width so
it's just a bit easier when you're
working with elements like that then we
also want to inherit that box sizing
border box to all elements so
using the wild card selector here as
well as the before pseudo element
and the after pseudo element selector
and they're going to
inherit the box sizing board box in the
html
element now for the body
element let's add some sort of resets
here
so we'll say margin zero padding zero i
also like to do a line height
of 1.3 just to add some spacing between
lines and
we're going to add our fonts in as well
we look at the style guide it said that
the
font that we're using is public sans i'm
going to go to
our browser here copy this in
i think it wanted to use 300 light and
then
400 regular so we'll select both of
those
and we're going to embed it we'll just
copy this
link tag here and put it in our
index.html
over here above the title
now since we're in the index.html file
let's also
add a link tag for our css file
i'm going to create a dist folder and i
want to put all my final css files
in there so i'm going to say disk
style.css
and then we also i think want to add
a script
to load our javascript file that one's
just going to be in the app folder so
app.js
script.js let's go into our folder here
and create that
script.js then we'll just add some test
code so we can test it
hello world why not now that we have
some sas files
you know just basic styles added let's
also test out
our sas workflow to compile my sas to
css i like to use this extension
called live sas compiler so if you don't
have this installed yet
you can just type in live sas compiler
in the extensions marketplace
and click this button to install it you
might need to restart vs code if you're
installing it for the first time now but
once you have that set up
when you open a project file you should
see some buttons in the bottom one says
watch sas and the other one says go live
so if we click that watch sas button
going to watch our sas files and
then if you want to go live we click the
go live button
and it should load the local website in
our browser we can see that that is
indeed the case
obviously this doesn't look too fancy
since you know
we just added the text from the design
here but we can also
check down in the console window here
and our hello world message is loading
so it looks like everything's working
correctly
see we need to add that font to our code
so
in our globals we're going to say font
family and
let's do that before line height font
family
i believe it was called public sans
so we're just going to copy this over
there we go
okay so let's check our browser again
and we don't need this anymore
so it looks like we have the font public
sans
successfully imported so now going back
to our vs code
we want to do is we want to basically
start creating
the markup for our website so let's go
into our index.html file
and we're going to start writing markup
over here i'm just going to actually
comment out
all the copy from the design just so we
don't have this extra stuff
you know visible on the website we're
going to start writing our markup so
let's go back to
our design and what i'm going to do is
try to do the mobile first
approach and we're going to make our
default styles without media queries the
mobile styles
and we're going to build the mobile
website first and what i usually do is
i'll go from the top down so let's start
with the header
but taking a look at the header it has a
logo on the left and it has a hamburger
button on the right which then
when you open it opens this mobile menu
then if we compare that to what we have
for the desktop design
it also has a logo on the left that has
some links looks like in the middle
and then there's a cta button on the
right side so
let's create the markup and styles for
this header
in our body tag i'm going to create a
header
and then in that header we want to add
our logo image
and we're also going to assume that this
is going to link to
the home page so we'll just make that
open that
and then in this anchor tag we want to
add our image for the logo
so image source images and then we want
to look for this logo
svg then alt oops
i'll we'll call that easy bank since
that's the name of the
plate we're making let's see if that
loaded on our site
okay so that was easy right i think
actually what i want to do in addition
to that is create a
nav and i'm going to put everything in
that navigation in this nav tag what we
got is
the logo and then we have our hamburger
menu on the right so that's
probably also going to be an anchor link
it's just going to go to the same page
and we want to create a hamburger menu
and the hammer we're going to use those
three lines so let's create three spans
so we're gonna use an emmett shortcut
span times three so three empty spans
and we also probably need a class for
this and we're just gonna call this
hamburger
for the hamburger menu and in the same
way maybe we can create a class up here
for the logo so we'll say class
equals logo
if we look back at the design we can see
that everything is in one line
so that tells me that this nav element
should probably be a flexbox parent
to put everything on the same line now
one other thing i like to do is i like
to use a lot of helper classes
so instead of having to write display
flex on every single element in this
webpage that is a flexbox parent
we're going to create a helper class
called flex and i'm going to add that in
our globals got it there
so flexbox styles
we'll say flex class and we're going to
say display
flex and let's add a few other
flex related classes so flex
um one property we use a lot is justify
content so let's say
jc dash
space between and that will be justify
content space between because that is
used quite often
you can also maybe create one for center
and i'm just going to basically be
creating these as you know as we need
them
so let's also create some align content
properties so align content and usually
it's aligned content center
so we'll write that align content or i'm
sorry align items rather
center so it's a
i enter okay so
this is fine for now we're probably
going to use more later but now what
we've done
is in my sas i've created a flex class
for display flex and then these other
ones for the flex
properties so i can do now is uh
let's see split this up so you can see
our html on the left and our styles on
the right
what i'm going to do is in the nav in
addition to the flex class we also want
a flex
justify content space between so let's
just check out how it looks in the
browser
okay so you can see our logo here let's
see what's going on
so we can see the nav here so we have a
logo and then we have the hamburger
class but it looks like that has a
zero width and
box model yeah it looks like it has a
no width but there is a height so what
we probably need to do
is make those spans spans by nature are
our display inline
so that means they're not going to take
up any space so there's like no content
in them
so what we want to do is we want to add
some styles now for our header
so we go back to our sas folder create a
new sas file
i'm going to call this header.scss
and then we want to make sure that we
are
importing that into our main sas file so
just trying to
keep things organized here
header so now in our header what we want
to do
is i think i'm going to add another
class for
the header let's say class
header and this is so i can use bam
block element modifier
for writing my sas classes so first we
have this main element header
and then in here we're going to say
maybe header underscore underscore logo
and then header underscore underscore
menu maybe hamburger menu okay so now
in our sas files we can start using the
ampersand for header
then there's a logo and then another one
for the menu
this is the mobile menu so we'll just
add a little comment here saying that
mobile menu
and we also have an image tag here
so i'm not sure if we're going to need
this but we'll just add it here anyway
so in the menu we have some span
elements i'm just going to use the
direct
child selector here to make sure
we keep things as specific as possible
and we're going to say display
block for these spans now if we go back
to the design
the hammer menu is looks like a bunch of
dark
black or very dark gray lines so
we're going to start with some general
styles here
first thing was first actually we
probably want to get
our colors added in from the style guide
so you can see here
these are all the different colors
they're using hsl instead of hex but
that's totally fine
so let's start adding variables for our
colors so we can reuse them
so dark blue
and now we're probably going to use this
dark blue color for the hamburger menu
and we'll just kind of see how that
looks
so let's close our script file here we
don't really need that right now
it's going back to our header sas file
we want those lines to be that dark blue
color so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to
say width and the width of those
hamburger lines are now since this is a
jpeg
this is kind of the only way that we can
really see how big things are
i'm creating a little rectangle here
that's semi-transparent so you can still
see through it
but you can still move it around and you
can kind of use it to see how big things
are
pretty small looks like it's about
a 26 and then about 12 or 13 height okay
so what i want to do is here i'm going
to set this to i think was 26 pixels
and then the height of each this is just
for each line
so let's say two pixels oh yeah and then
the background color
background color and we'll use the dark
blue variable
all right let's see how that looks on
our website now okay so
it's a little small up here but we do
have our hamburger lines here but we
need to add some spaces
between the lines so what i'm going to
do is i want to add
a margin bottom to all the spans except
the last one so
what we can do is we can use the not
selector so not
last child
and then if it's not the last child
we'll say margin bottom
and let's just kind of guess here maybe
three pixels
now going back to our website we can see
now that we do have the
three lines and our logo now of course
everything's up right on the edge here
so we need to add
some padding here so let's see how much
padding there is
let's get the top and bottom padding
first
i'm going to kind of assume that the top
and bottom padding are the same
if we have a little rectangle here about
22 inches
or pixels rather and if we move it down
it might be a little bit more so maybe
24.
so 24 pixels of padding on top and
bottom and then for left and right
about the same let's just say 24 all
around so going back into our code
what we can do is we want to add padding
to the
nav itself so in the header
we're going to add another selector here
for the nav
just no class at least for now so we'll
say padding
uh 24 pixels all around okay so let's
see how that looks
all right oh why is that so tall let's
see what's going on here
so we have a nav here that's one of our
pixels all around
it looks like we need to center things
vertically so what i didn't do is i need
to add
another flex property here so flex
just to show you what i got here flex a
i
see that's going to align items to
center all right so that looks a bit
more
centered there we go okay so we got our
now we got our spacing
one thing we do want to do is see what
the differences are between the mobile
and then the desktop
nav mobile obviously has the hamburger
menu
does not have these links or the cta so
these are
desktop only but i should be able to use
the same markup for both mobile and
desktop
so let's add some elements in for the
links as well as the cta
okay so let's scoot this over here a bit
so logo's first for both and then for
the mobile the
menu is over here now since the
the hamburger is not going to be visible
on desktop i'm just going to add these
other elements down here
so the first one you want to do is since
i'm using flexbox to separate them out
let's create a new element we'll just
say
div and we'll say header underscore
underscore links
then in here we'll say anchor
um link so i think there were
how many links five
link times five there we go and i think
the text is down here so
you can just kind of move those up into
here into the links
so header links and you know this is
just a landing page we're doing so we're
just going to make all the links
the pound sign or the hashtag
so going back to our header sas file
we're probably going to have to add some
styles for that
so under the menu
will say header underscore underscore
links
and in that is going to be some anchor
links
let's go back to our website and now we
can see
that we have our links okay first things
we want to get rid of that underline
and i want that to be true for all links
on the page so
we're going to add some styles
here for just default styles so links
a visited a hover
um text decoration none
okay good now let's style those links
let's see what we got here
check our notes in the style guide okay
it says font size is 18 pixels
i guess we could add that font size to
the body tag
so 18 pixels and it's actually better to
use
relative units like rems instead of
pixels so
to get from pixels to rams you can
divide 18 by 16.
so if we check this inspect element
see yep font size is 1.125 rams and if
you click on the computer tab it'll tell
you it's 18 pixels which is what we want
okay color seems to be this actually
seems smaller so this might be like
maybe 16 or even 14. let's find out
it's about 14. so we're going to adjust
the font size in the um better
font size i think we said 14 so 14
pixels divided by 16 is 0.875
um another thing you can actually do and
let's do that now is we're going to
create some variables for these font
sizes
just in case we need to reuse them so
we'll say
body or maybe font
medium the 18 pixels or
font size 1.125 rims
and then we'll replace this
with the variable name the other one was
font small this is going to be
14 pixels there we go
take that over here and we'll replace
that with the font small variable
kind of helps just to add some comments
so you can remember what this is
18 pixels we'll add more variables as we
need
but for now let's also check out the
colors
probably that lighter gray for the text
here so i think i can actually i might
just add it to the body selector since
it seems like
most of the body text is that gray color
so let's add that in the global one as
well
this just makes it so that you don't
have to
add you know font size and color for
every different element you can just add
it
globally first to the body for whatever
you know the most often used one is
and then you can make them different for
the elements that need that let's check
out this website
where's the color coming from looks
almost purple
not gray there should be another color
hopefully
uh it's probably this light grayish blue
so we'll just replace that
there we go i wonder if this is from the
link color change to red
yeah it's not taking for some reason i
think it's probably taking the default
color from the browser
so what i want to do is
let's add that color property there okay
that's a little bit too
that's a little bit too light so we're
just going to go back to the grayish
blue
and same for here there we go
okay that looks more like it so now we
have the links added
we want to add that cta button that's
just for desktop
so let's move this over here because
we're going to need that pretty soon
this is going to be probably a button
element
so we'll say button type equals
button and then what does it say request
invite
okay so now it's a button now of course
we need to style these button styles
so we're going to add the button styles
again in our globals
so first thing i want to do is we want
to kind of reset the
colors and different styles so this
one is a gradient background and it has
rounded corners
what we probably want to do is figure
out what the size of the button is so we
can do that by i'm just going to add
padding to the sides so it's about 16
padding on top about the same on the
bottom
and then oops for the left and right
it's about
let's just say 30. so we'll say 16
padding on top and bottom and then 30
on left and right
so we're going to use the button element
as well as the button class just in case
because sometimes we might want to have
an anchor link
that has the button class as well
padding 16 on top
so that's one rim and then 30
which would be 30 divided by 16 1.875
around this okay and then also around a
corner so border radius
um i'm not sure we'll just say 50 pixels
for now okay let's see how that looks
okay getting there we also probably want
to make it use the cursor when you hover
over it
there we go so now it looks like it's a
link looking back at the design
this is a gradient looks like it's a
linear gradient just going from
left to right so going from this green
color to this kind of
teal blue green color let's see which
colors
we're going to be using it's probably
lime green going to bright cyan
so let's add it i like adding the
background here
background linear gradient
and it's going to go lime green
to bright cyan
okay so it's horizontally i don't want
to make it go kind of vertical
so i think it is too right i'm not
positive that's the correct
syntax and it looks like it's not css
linear gradient this is what i do quite
a bit when i'm
building websites so we can go to let's
check out mdn
okay two left comma so i need to add a
comma there
and let's go back to our website oh
still didn't work what's going on here
i am not using the right property
background linear gradient to
left let's kind of inspect this in the
thing itself linear gradient that's
right
to dash right no
there's no dash that's why just test
this to make sure
i think i need to edit in the code
itself
there we go oh yeah i think we need to
get rid of that border
so in buttons we're going to say border
zero okay so now that's gone which is
good
then we want the color to be white
nice and let's see how that matches
looks like it might be bold actually
font weight we'll say 700 for bold
although it said it was
let's check our notes again weights 300
and 400.
go back to the design here so i'm
guessing the default weight is the
300 for light and the normal is
sort of the headline stuff so let's kind
of go back into our body
font weight we want default weight to be
300
and then for the link we'll say the
weight is 400 since
it is a little bit heavier
is that taking um font weight 300 which
is good
check this out want weight is 400
it doesn't look any different weird
okay i think this might be because it is
a button element
um if we do font
weight 300 font weight
400. seem to change at all
changes to an anchor link
yeah it is changing a bit so this might
just be a bug
for the button element maybe we'll just
change that button to
an actual anchor link
because it could be an acrylic in real
life it really just depends on
what you want to do add a class
and we'll say class of button now we
know that this should inherit all these
styles here so let's check this again
okay looks like the weight is correct
pretty big i think
in the design it looks like it was the
same size
so let's go back to header
this is maybe header underscore
underscore cta
so font size we'll just make this also
font small
and color will make this white
uh why is this gray oh my gosh nothing's
working
what color red
important
oh my it's because it's the anchor link
oh okay probably because oh yeah i did
this color grayish blue
i might actually just get rid of this
thing here
and instead add it to the anchor links
because it's a bit more specific because
i don't want every single
link to necessarily be that grayish blue
color there we go
that looks pretty good all the links are
there so the next thing we want to do is
we want to
either hide or show the different
navigation elements depending on if
they're needed on the mobile design and
then the desktop design
so how we're going to control that is
another set of helper classes
this is going to be a bit more
complicated because first i need to
create
the classes we'll just call this
visibility so
hide for mobile i'm including tablet
with this mobile
class so in this what we want to do is
hide
for tablet and mobile devices and we'll
create another one hide for
desktop hide for desktop
widths viewport widths so the way we're
going to target this
is we need to create a media query but
what i'm going to do is create a mixin
so we can make things a bit more
reusable let's create a new
sas file called mixins
and this one's going to be related to
breakpoints the final code that we want
to have
is something like media
and then the target will be min width
1024 pixels for desktop
1024 divided by 16 64. and for
media queries you want to use ems
they've just been shown to be the most
consistent
among browsers and then we have our
styles go here
this is what we want to output but we
want to save these
break points so we don't have to keep
typing them every time right so
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a sas map we're going to call
this
breakpoints up and then we're going to
basically create a bunch of different
values for breakpoints up meaning at
this point and bigger
use these styles so to do that we're
going to first create one for
medium because we're assuming the small
size
is the default one 640
pixels divided by 16 is 40 ems
40 ems i'll create another one for a
large
and let's say that one's going to be 10
24 pixels
divide by 16 is 64. and we'll create
another one for extra large
since we have a lot of large screens
these days
1400 divided by 16.
so 87.5 ems
so now this is our sas map for
breakpoints up but
i'm also going to create one for break
points down the first one breakpoints up
is if you want to
target this viewport and up and that's
what i use for most of my styles but
there are some cases
where you want to target a style from a
certain viewport and on down
so for that we're going to not use the x
large
because x large on down is basically
everything but we are going to add a
small here for mobile devices
for mobile we're going to take this
value here because
medium would be 40 ems and on and on up
for small we're going to say 40 ends and
down
and we'll move this up here from medium
on down so this is anything
smaller than 10 24 and then 87.5
ems oops i need to leave that there
we don't want to overlap these so i'm
just going to make these one pixels
smaller the breakpoints we're using
are 640 pixels 10 24 pixels and i think
i said 1400 pixels
that's for the break points up so for
these we want it to be
640 and up so 639 and down
this is so we don't have any overlapping
styles
i try to not mix breakpoints up and
break points down in the same style rule
it's either one or the other usually
going to be break points up we need to
recalculate these numbers here
this is going to be 639 divided by 16.
39.9375
9 and then 1023
divided by 16. 63.9375
and the last one is going to be 13.99
87.4375
there we go now we have our two maps
what we can do now is create our mixin
so we're going to say
mix in break point up
it's going to take a parameter we'll
just call it size i'm going to
write what we want the the mixing 2
output so we want to output a media
query so media
and then min width and this is where
we're going to put in this
size variable i'm sorry this is not
right
so the min width is going to be the the
the value
for that size that we've determined so
to get that we need to use
map dash get so you can see this code
has some helper
text here turns value in a map
associated with the given key so map get
and the map we're using is going to be
for the first one
break points up we also want to grab
that
size parameter so the size is going to
be either small medium large
x large and will return this ems number
when we're using this mix-in we want to
write this media query and then in the
media query we're going to just output
whatever content
is in the style and i'll show you how
that works in a second
we got our mixing written or breakpoint
up and let's create another one for
break point down
and everything's going to be pretty much
the same except reasonably down
and then also instead of min width is
going to be max width
and then the content so going into our
global styles again the hide for mobile
class we want to
hide for medium and down so we're going
to
call the mixin by using include and we
want to do
break point down and
the size we're going to call is going to
be the medium
because for medium and down we want to
say display none
and then in a similar way for the
desktop
we want to call a mixin but the one
mixing we're going to use is going to be
breakpoint
up because we want to hide the element
using this
class for desktop and up so that would
be large and extra large
display none okay now let's see if this
works by adding these classes to the
different elements in the
header so for mobile we want to hide
those links as well as that cta so let's
add the class here
and then for desktop we want to hide the
hamburger menu since we don't need that
for desktop
and we're going to keep the logo because
that's going to be used for both
okay so now moment of truth let's see
how this works looks like something's
not really working
but let's see yeah this is when we debug
our code
so hide from mobile and for desktop
interesting looks like there's no errors
so what we want to do
is maybe check out the final css file
there we go let's see if we can find
that class
oh looks like we didn't even
didn't even get pulled in for some
reason that's weird
oh wait there's a error here no mixing
named breakpoint down
okay let's go back and start from the
beginning oh
we didn't add the mixins sass file so
let's let's do that that seems
pretty important now we go okay now
there's a success message
go back to our site oh my gosh what's
going on here
okay so it does look like things are
hiding and showing
so let's see when when does this switch
potentially four and up it's showing the
links and the button and then
yeah so hide for desktop display none or
the
the hamburger menu then here
there's no styles here but as soon as we
get shorter
use the hide from mobile so at 10 24 is
when everything
either gets hidden or shown so this
looks like
it is working let's look at the design
again and just make sure we have all the
styles
correctly we need some more space
between these links here so
let's see how much space we need to add
it's about maybe
32 pixels so going into our header sas
file
header links a what we're going to do is
we're going to add a margin to
the right of the link but we don't add a
right margin to the last link because
there's nothing after that
so we're going to use a not selector and
then not
last child so as long as it's not the
last child
margin right is going to be what do we
say
32 pixels
all right so now let's make sure there's
no
margin added to that last link
contact blog why is there white space
here
and then queers does not have it so the
white space is probably
added because of the enter key
um there we go okay now there's no white
space that's weird
let's go back here check one more time
let's check this button styles again
152 by 50 seems a little bit big to me
i feel like some of the padding might
not be quite accurate
here is our div 163 by 44
and let's kind of guess what this font
size is
it's probably 14 which i think it should
be
correct let's double check the font
first and then we'll adjust the padding
to match so if we go to computed
and see that the font size
is 14 so that's right so we're just
going to adjust the padding here
the pattern right now is 16 on the top
and bottom
it's 50 pixels tall right now and it
should be 46 we need to
subtract 4 pixels so 2 pixels from the
top and bottom
so let's go back to our button styles
and here's the padding so one round
which is 16 pixels but we want to
subtract that and make it 14. um 14
divided by 16.
0.875
rem there you go
so now it's 46 which is pretty good and
then it should be 163
and it's only 152 so it's about 10 so
we'll add five more to each the left and
the right
right now it is 30. we want to be 35 on
each
so 35 divided by 16 is 2.1875
2.1875 okay so that looks a bit more
like the design 162 by 46
which looks much closer yeah that looks
pretty good
and let's actually double check this
logo size as well for both
mobile and desktop it looks like they're
the same size for both
let's just make sure it's about
141x22 if it's the same for mobile
yeah it's the same let's see what the
actual logo is here
139 by 20 and it should be 141 by 22.
so let's see where this gets set i think
it's in the header
oh we didn't even set the size okay so
it needs to be 141 by 22.
so 141 divided by 16
8.8125
and then height should be 22
[Music]
1.375
okay let's see if that helps at all
alrighty
the 141 by 22
141 by 22. all right
this is pretty good so we got our mobile
styles here
for the hamburger menu as we get bigger
we got the desktop styles
so let's check out the active states for
desktop we go over here
looks like the text gets darker and oh
we have this border here
and then for the button it looks like it
gets sort of
like whited out a little bit yeah it
looks like that
so first let's tackle the that bottom
border
and the color for the text so
the header links i'm going to do is for
the hover
pseudo selector we want the color to be
the darker gray so it was grayish blue
here so it's probably this dark blue
color here
let's double check on that nice
and to make it a little bit nicer we can
add a transition
so transition for the color and
the timing for that let's just say maybe
200 milliseconds
and then i like to do ease in out for
most transitions
there we go so you can see it's a little
you know just a little bit nicer
let's figure out how to do that bottom
gradient so the problem is here right
now
these elements are just the width or the
height of the text itself
so what i will need to do is i need to
add some either margin or padding
for the top and our bottom to make it
the height of the probably the entire
thing because we're centering everything
remember
so where's my little rectangle where'd
it go
i left it over here oh there's another
one down there
like this one we'll take this one in
case we need it later make it bigger so
we can see it
let's take that over here and see how
tall this thing needs to be
looks like the header itself is
about probably 80 pixels tall is what we
would guess
and then the little border thing is
about 5 pixels tall
let's go back to our site add some
border so we can see what we're doing
here
i can see that this has a border this is
actually a little bit tall as well
and it really should be 80 pixels tall
it's probably the padding the header has
no padding the nav has padding here
24 pixels of padding so let's try
and we should probably convert that to
rams as well so if the total height is
going to be 80
we can take this down so 17 pixels and
24 pixels
or header nav padding
and then if we want to convert that to
rems
1.0625
and then 24 1.5
okay so now it is 80 pixels tall which
is
pretty much about what we wanted let's
see if we can do it with
a pseudo element not sure if this is
going to work
let's just say for this one
um header links a
new set of styles here airlinks a b4
so content needs to be an empty string
so let's try
position absolute width of 100
display block
and we'll make it a height of 5 pixels
and then background of let's just say
you know the lime green color so the
suit elements going all the way across
which we don't want it to do
i thought this position relative would
work
let's try adding it here okay
there we go maybe we'll try to align it
to the zero
left of zero right of zero
so instead of width we're just saying
left and right so now
each link has a little line which is
what we want but
it doesn't seem like it's in the right
place and i think it's because we want
to
adjust it so that it's right up to the
header
so now we want this green line to be
down where the blue line is so let's see
if we can do that
we might actually just need to add a
static let me think about this
what we could do is say bottom zero
negative statically set it to 30. that
might actually be the easiest one so
let's do that
okay so before we forget let's copy
these styles
so header links a i'm going to say
position relative
and then the header links a let's add
this here
so before
let me content empty
and then let's just kind of copy those
other styles that we'd added here
okay so now this actually worked oops
what did i do what did i do looks like
set position relative hmm what did i do
oh i didn't add position absolute
there we go there we go
i think it was happening before was
position relative and you just made them
stack for some reason
makes every element a display block
which takes up 100 width
and then it's in the flow of the
document
interesting okay anyway so here we got
our
lines now what we want to do is make the
colors correct first of all
and we're going to only show the line
when you're hovering
if we look over here it looks like let's
see it has the same green actually as
the button it goes from lime green to
blue
so let's go back to our button styles so
here's the linear gradient
i wonder if we're using this gradient
again in this website
so it's using the buttons which is
already taken care of this i'm assuming
are just
icons this is just green
i think we'll be okay just leaving the
styles
like this and then we can just copy it
if if it was used multiple times i might
create like a helper class for that but
let's just leave it like this for now
and then we also only want that to
appear on hover
so when you hover on the element itself
the pseudo element will get this
background
that's cool now we need to figure out a
way to make this
more transitioned because it's a little
bit you know kind of jarring just like
suddenly pops up
as opposed to the color of the text like
itself
what we can do is unfortunately you
cannot
make the background itself
you can't make the background itself
transition it just
doesn't work that way so what we're
gonna do is we're going to
put the background back in the
pseudo-element by default but we're
going to make
opacity zero and then
when it's hovered we'll change the
opacity
to one and then we can add the
transition here
opacity 300 milliseconds
ease and it'll be the same
oh wait 200 milliseconds
so now let's get rid of that border too
don't need that let's see what this
looks like
now you can see it is fading in and out
pretty nicely
might make it a little bit slower let's
make them 300
for both
okay so now it's a pretty nice little
transition here
okay so i think these text links are
good let's move on to the
hover state for that button let's look
at the design one more time
it looks like it just kind of fades to
white so i wonder if we can just
make this adjust the opacity let's see
what this looks like
opacity let's try 0.75
see what that switches look that's
pretty good
okay so button header cta
in the header let's find the cta and
then we're going to add a transition
for the opacity again and we'll do the
same thing 300 milliseconds oops
ease in out now
on hover um we'll say opacity
is zero okay so let's see how that looks
now
whoa oh it doesn't want to be 0.75 i
think i said
that wouldn't be very good user
experience that's pretty good
for making this hamburger menu the first
thing is we need to turn
this hamburger into an x when you click
on it so some kind of cool animation
second thing that happens is this
overlay will in some way shape or form
appear over the rest of the website
and then on top of the overlay will be
the actual mobile menu
then clicking on the x will animate it
back into the hamburger
the overlay will disappear and the
mobile menu itself will also disappear
in some way so the first thing i'm going
to do
is starting with the hamburger menu
animate it from hamburger to x
so to do that let's do a little bit of
research online so i'm going to go to
codepen
dot io and i will type in
hamburger menu and just kind of see what
happens
see what we can find here i do want to
mention before we
get into this is that even though you
can
legally copy any code you find on
codepen i try to
do research see what other people have
done terms of solutions see what they've
built but then try to build it myself
so this is really just the steps that i
take
to build something just to do some
research
that's kind of cool let me try hamburger
animation
that's really the specific thing we're
looking for here i don't want anything
too flashy or too fancy
um yeah that's a little too much for me
and i just wanted to include this part
in the video because i do feel like
researching is a very important part of
coding you always have to invent
everything from scratch
okay i actually kind of like this
animation the middle bar disappears it
fades out and
the two the top and bottom bars form the
x so let's just see
what they did here they've added some
transitions onto this
and transform origin line
two goes to opacity zero so it fades out
so it looks like line one i'm assuming
is the top one rotates 45 degrees
so it's angled the bottom line is going
to rotate negative 45 degrees
and i do like how this looks so i think
i'm going to just try to build this
animation one thing that i think i'm
going to do
which is a bit different from a design
is i'm going to make this hamburger menu
a little bit taller and more
square because we can see the x is
actually square and it looks taller
than the hamburger menu we'll make that
change then we'll start adding in the
animation
so what i did here was basically added
three pixels of margin bottom to the
first two spans
it's 26 by 14 height right now i know 26
by 26 is really what i want
we'll just try to eyeball it honestly
let's do five pixels
this is the header underscore underscore
menu
this is one benefit of using the bem
styling because i know everything has to
be in the header sass file there we go
five and we'll go back here okay
that looks pretty good i think i'm going
to add a class
on this header menu so that when it's
open that will sort of turn on the
animation
okay so header menu go back here so
header menu
then i'll add a helper class and we'll
just say
open so in the header let's kind of
refer back to our markup as well
so this here is the mobile menu so those
spans in the header underscore
underscore menu
if header underscore in a square menu
has a class of open as well
then we're going to transform those
spans
span first child
and we'll add another one or last child
and then i think i need to add one for
the middle child there's no middle child
selector but i think we can do nth child
i think it should be
two because i think the number for those
starts with one
so when it has class of open we're going
to do transform
rotate 45 degrees
then for the last child we'll do
negative 45 degrees
and then the middle child will say
opacity zero
and the reason i'm doing opacity instead
of like display none is because
you can't transition display block to
display none you have to do
opacity which can use a transition now
let us test this in the browser it's
going to reload
and of course i didn't add any
javascript or anything yet so we're just
going to add manually the open class to
the menu
that doesn't look too good i think it
has to do with the transform
origin because right now what is
happening is
they're kind of just rotating themselves
wherever their middle is
let's add a transition then we can kind
of see that a bit more clearly
transition will say all
300 milliseconds ease in out
all right let's try this again we can
add a class of open
take a look at the hamburger menu yes
you can see
each line is kind of rotating on
wherever the center
is the middle one's fine because it's
just disappearing so i
actually kind of need to look back at
that
because you can see that you want the
transform origin to be
on the sort of left side let's kind of
see what they did here
okay transform origin 20 ammonium i
haven't used transform origin really
before so let's google that
transform origin i try to look at
mozilla
developer network when i can okay
transform origin sets the origin for an
element's transformations
it's rotating the origin is the center
and i'm assuming that's default so let's
try top left
instead of just rotating from the center
it's the corner is kind of where
the rotation starts so that might be
what we want for the
first line let's just try transform
origin
top maybe center left since they're just
lines
let's just add it for all of them
transform
origin center left
or let's do left center i don't know
which one needs to be first
i'm not sure if it matters let's add
this open thing again
getting closer i think i'm actually
going to
add the javascript here so i don't have
to keep manually adding it in
i don't really need the hello world
anymore for clicking on this
i'm actually going to add an id because
i like to use ids for the javascript
functionality so
button hamburger and then
take this id then the script.js will say
document
query selector and selector is going to
be the hash
button hamburger and then let's add
event listener
and it's going to be a click then when
you add it it'll run this function
i always use a little console logs to
test first open
hamburger const
[Music]
hamburger equals the button hamburger
over here
actually let's just call it button
hamburger then we can reuse this
constant that we created
when you click the hamburger i'm going
to run this console.log message and then
i also want to
add a class and we can do this with
classlist
dot add and then the class name we want
to add
click hamburger so i'm gonna use a
little if statement here so if
button hamburger class list contains
if it has open the open class
i want to remove it otherwise i want to
add the open class
that should take care of the
functionality we need for now
let's click on this look at that
add the open class and click on it again
and it removes it
okay so this looks good obviously this
is x looks a bit
weird we just need to kind of adjust the
transform origin i think let's try zero
pixels
zero pixels just to see what happens
oh look at this boy this looks weird
oh that looks much better three pixels
in one pixel
in the header or was that oh transform
origin there we go
let's try again clicking on the
hamburger menu
nice looks like a nice little x hey look
at that
okay so this is the first functionality
of the hamburger menu
next thing we want to do is we want to
load the overlay
because we don't have any regular
content in the website i'm just going to
maybe add some stuff just so you can see
the overlay opening over the regular
content
we'll just uncomment all of the html
here
okay so the next thing i'm going to do
is we want to load an overlay so going
back to the design
the overlay it appears under the white
navigation bar and then just over
everything else
so the headers here and the nav is
included in that
so i could do a couple things i could
create an overlay on the same level as a
header
and then just make sure the header has a
higher z index so it's on top of the
overlay so let's try that actually
so here's the header i'm just going to
add a div class
overlay
okay so to make the overlay let's look
at the design again
so it starts with this gray color i'm
assuming it's this
sort of blue gray color which we can use
and then it's a linear gradient
which fades as you go down to
transparent first let's get the color
that we need
it's probably this dark blue here the
overlay
let's just add a background color as
a fallback
then linear gradient
oh wait background image
linear gradient
and i always forget what the
but let's just try transparent
we'll see i am a professional web
developer but i do look up a lot of
stuff okay so looks like
that's the correct linear gradient thing
so we do need to make this
um cover everything and i want to
do position absolute
and then we'll just set top to zero for
now right
zero bottom zero
left zero actually i think i might need
to do a fixed
because it's sort of going like this so
you need to
basically set the height of it to 100 vh
so the viewport height i think this
should
accomplish the same thing we'll see oh
look at that overlay
oh yeah so i don't really want that
i can use the shorthand those two
2d 314d hmm
that's not what i want
[Music]
um css gradient
fallback color um
let's try linear gradient
here we go there's a way to use these
gradients and fallback colors
that's what i did background color yada
yada
background image oh fallback image
i don't know if that's actually because
i did that but then it just
add the background color
like this um what if i did this
nope
well i guess that
[Music]
okay yes yes yes weird i don't know why
this is not working
well in any case maybe we'll just get
rid of that
background color weird i will just
delete it
this is kind of what we want i want to
make sure the text goes sort of taller
than
what we can do so we'll just do this
let's just do
there we go okay so you can scroll down
overlays fix
which is pretty good obviously now it's
covering up the header so we don't want
that
so for here we need to i think declare
the position
set the position rather or i think what
we need to do is
make the top the height of the
nav bar so this is about
60. we'll just say top is 60 pixels
there we go now we have our overlay we
got top to 60.
actually we should use rems so we'll do
our little dividing game here
60 divided by 16 is 3.75 rams
now um we also want to control this with
a css
class so before we if we add the open
class to the
hamburger it'll open what i could do
is try to just use one css class to
control
all the animations so i think i'm going
to add the open class to the header
instead of the button hamburger itself
open so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take this
and then i'm going to add another
section here hamburger
open styles and
the overlay into the header and then
we'll add
our open styles here and we'll put it in
the header itself of course
i'll set it at the top
so if if the header has class open then
i'm going to say
um header menu we need to add these
styles here so what i'm doing is i'm
basically
moving that all the open styles into if
the header element has the open class
not the header menu let's now test these
adjusted styles
and update our javascript so that we are
adding the open class in the
header element itself so create a new
constant
we'll just call this header and we'll
use the same
document query selector and we will
select
the class of header element
so now instead of checking if the button
hamburger
has the open class we're going to change
it to checking if the header
has the open class we'll update these
to remove the open class from the header
and then here we'll
add the open class to the header so what
this is doing now
is when you click the button you're
going to check if the header has the
open class
and if it doesn't have it added and if
it does have it remove it
let's test this out in our site what we
hope
will happen is when we click this it'll
add the open class
oh yeah oh yeah it works
it's always a good feeling when the code
does what you wanted to do the first
time without having to tweak it
okay let's go back into our scss and
i'm also going to start animating the
overlay because right now
on the side it's just kind of like there
let's take a look at here
in the header we have the overlay and
it's positioned fixed
so i'm going to create a css animation a
keyframe animation
and i'm going to attach it to a helper
class
actually i'm probably going to attach it
to the if the header has the open class
then using that css keyframe animation
it's going to fade in
or fade out the overlay we might have to
tweak a little bit as we go but that's
kind of general idea
i think what i'm going to do is by
default i want to make the overlay
display
none and then we will
fade it in probably using the opacity
and transition
and then fade it out when we close the
menu
so i'm going to create a new sas file
actually so in our app
scss folder let's create a new file i'm
going to call this
animation so any keyframe animations
we're going to
load in this animation sas file and then
of course we want to
actually load it import it in the main
sas file
so animations there we go actually let's
just put it
up under the mixins just to keep things
kind of organized
so these are like the functional sas
styles and then
starting here is where we have elements
in the different component styles
keyframe animations you start by typing
at
key frames and then you
write a name for what the animation is
so what i want to do is i'm going to
create
maybe two animations for the overlay i'm
just going to call them fade in and fade
out so the first one's going to be fade
in
and with keyframes you start
with a from and then you end with a 2
and then you put
the initial styles in the from bracket
and then the end of styles in the
two bracket and you can also add
percentage of progress
in here so if i wanted to i could say
let's say 50
do something let's indent this a little
bit or
any percent you want and then it'll use
that to time when certain animations
take place
this is more if you have like complex
animations what we're doing in is a
pretty simple fade and so i think i
might be able to get away with just
using from into
okay so in the header sas file the
overlay has a default display of none
and then in the animations i'm just
going to add display
none just because it's where we're
starting
and then i want to end up having a
display
block and
opacity of one
and we're also going to start with an
opacity of zero now the tricky thing
about
this is you can transition opacity from
zero to one it'll have a nice
smooth animation from zero to one but
you can't transition display none to
display block that's just not
how css works first it's gonna be
display none then i'm going to say maybe
one percent so right after it starts
it's going to be display
block but it's going to be opacity still
of zero
and then from one percent to basically
100 the end
it will stay at display block but then
it's going to transition from zero to
one
we can try this out by adding this
animation in our styles
and i'll just add the overlay styles up
here so if the header is open
then the overlay is going to have
animation
and it actually gives you a little help
here so name duration timing function
um direction things like that the name
is
the name that we added here so fade dash
in
duration let's just say 300 milliseconds
that's kind of my default
timing function ease in out
is what i usually use and delay
i don't think i need a delay iteration
count you know how many times you want
this to happen
we just want it to happen once so i
think you don't need to add anything
there
and then direction we want forwards
and then fill mode i don't think i need
that i don't think i need that
so forwards this is actually important
because
saying forwards will ensure that once
the animation is complete
it will stay at whatever styles that
you've put
on the two otherwise it'll kind of
animate and then reset back to whatever
you had
styled before adding any animation so we
want to keep this display block opacity
one
after it's finished all right these are
the styles we need for the overlay
and let's i guess test it out okay so
you can see the header and then we can
see the overlay now is display none
let's click on this and see what happens
okay
looks like camera is still working but
the overlay is not
animating in
so we know the animation is being added
to the overlay but for some reason the
loading
isn't actually working and we're not
sure why what happens if i
uncheck the display none oh so it did
actually fade in look at that
for some reason it's not sticking the
end state is not staying on the thing
display none but it does have the
animation
okay time to google again or i guess
stuck that go
css animation final state maybe okay
maintaining the final say the end of
css3
thing and then i like using looking at
css tricks as well as
mdn so stack overflow css tricks and mdn
are kind of my
my main three sources that i go to okay
looks like this person's also
opacity changing from opacity zero to
one elements go back to opacity zero
animation fill mode is forwards well i
did use that i believe
yeah forwards maybe does the order
matter
in terms of what properties i put in
here i'm not really sure i mean it seems
like it's working if i
uncheck the display none so
i'm not sure what is happening it just
says forwards should make sure it'll
hold the last keyframe
state don't forget to specify 100 huh
i wonder if that does anything i don't
know if that's gonna work but let's
check on mdn
i don't know if you need the both 100
and the two this is just from
two yeah from 75 percent
to i don't think i need to actually say
100
i mean i guess i can't hurt let's just
try
i'm not even sure this is like good
syntax
okay let's try again
nope not working so i don't think it's
this i'm going to delete the 100 stuff
i know this is bad but i'm going to add
an important
to this see if that does anything
nope jeez this is kind of annoying fade
in
300 milliseconds easing out forwards
hmm it seems like i'm doing everything
right
but obviously it's not working let's
just get rid of this important because
that didn't help
i'm going to try commenting out the
display none just for now
and i'm going to try just setting it to
opacity 0 and see if that makes it
do anything different okay so it did
fade it in
so somehow adding a display block
is not getting added because
unfortunately i do
need the overlay to like be display none
otherwise i'm not going to be able to
click
things that are under the overlay
so let's put that back in oh what if i
okay by default overlay display none but
but what if i add display
block when it's open
oh my gosh this work whoa
that's so weird what if cs animations
don't actually
affect the display property at all that
could definitely be the case
let's look at this css does
css animation display block
because it might just maybe not affect
the display property at all and make
them just leave block display none
that's sort of what i'm looking for um
as you know
oh one of the properties that cannot be
animated is the display property
okay so that's why i mean i guess it
makes sense
although intuitively you would think
that you could add an animation from
display
none to display block and it would sort
of understand that you want to fade it
in
so i think i don't need to add any
display properties in the animation
since
obviously nothing's happening and
because i'm not doing that i think i
don't
even need the one percent thing because
i had just done that to make
it display block and opacity zero so
let's try this again
okay here's the overlay header doesn't
have open class let's click on it
oh yeah okay so
that's a fade in animation um and then
let's make another one that's going to
do the opposite
fade out fade out from opacity one
two opacity zero okay
i added the fade in animation when the
open class is
added i don't know if it'll work if i
add the fade out animation
or like the default let's just try it
we might need to add a helper class to
the actual overlay to fade it in and
fade it out
but let's just reload because i want to
make sure nothing weird happens with
this okay i just want to make sure that
because i added a fade out animation by
default
to the overlay i didn't want it to like
fade out when you load the page because
that would obviously look very strange
okay clicking on the hamburger menu fade
it in
very good and it just sort of
disappears so it doesn't have the
transition which means the animation is
not being added
so let's make this a little bit more
reusable so what i'm going to do is
i'll just add a little helper class fade
in
and then we'll take this and instead of
applying it specifically to the overlay
i'm going to add it to this helper class
here
so we can do the same thing with the
fade out
we'll add a little helper class i think
this might be a better practice anyway
because then i can fade in or fade out
any element using
these helper classes so just fade out
i do need to leave the display block
here just to flip it from display none
to display block
but what i think i need to do is in
javascript add that fade in and fade out
class
to the overlay so if header if it
contains open
remove opens this is when you close the
hamburger menu just so i don't
get things mixed up close hamburger menu
else add open class meaning open
hamburger menu
so when you open the hamburger menu we
want to add the fade in
class to the overlay so let's add a new
constant here
let's call this overlay document query
selector
and it's just a class of overlay
so when you open the hamburger menu
overlay
class list add
fade in let's just test the fade in
functionality now
go back to our site okay so you can see
the fade in class was added
and it's adding this animation
and then we'll do the sort of the
opposite we'll say
overlay classless add fade out
when you close it and might need to also
it just to kind of reset everything okay
let's try it again
reload for good measure all right it's
fading in
now what we want to happen is we want
the classes to basically swap when we
close the menu
it's fading in but it's not
oh you know what's happening it's
because
this when you remove the open class from
the header it immediately just like
goes back to display none shoot
it's kind of annoying but i think i need
to remove the overlay
getting the display block and instead
adding it to the overlay element itself
so it doesn't get affected
if the header has the open class or not
so overlay if it has class
fade in this is just going to do the
same thing of just
making it disappear oh boy this is tough
okay fades in still doesn't fade out
okay let's think about this what's
happening step by step
so okay going back to zero this is the
default state
you click on this it will add display
block
and then also fade it in the animation
works because
going from display none to display block
it's still opacity zero
so it's not going to like show up um
without the nice transition the animated
transition but then if you remove
if you remove that then it's going to
just display none right away so what we
want to do is
make it go from display block to display
none
after it fades out from opacity one two
opacity zero
so let's just research some other
possible solutions
um css animation display
well it's kind of what i was searching
for before display none
display block none
see what stack overflow has for us okay
yep
changing display none
okay cs or jquery ie javascript can't
animate between display none and display
block
i see 0 visibility hidden
interesting i just want to make sure
that the stuff is still clickable when
we have like a visibility hidden but it
still exists
get rid of this display none see rid of
opacity zero so now it is
default display block visibility hidden
it's interesting oh it seems like it's
actually still clickable
oh shoot this might be the silver bullet
i'm looking for
yeah so it's still clickable which is
awesome to see what happens is
it's just opacity zero it's not
clickable like i can't
select text as easily yeah i can't
select the text but
if it's visibility hidden
it does select the text and i think
visibility should be able to be animated
so
let's go back here so fade in we're
going to go from
visibility hidden
to this might be where we need to just
switch it quickly to
visibility visibility visible
with opacity zero so we're kind of
combining so it's sort of like display
block but
i guess it could be animated for
whatever reason then we'll do the same
thing
here so from opacity 1 visibility
visible
we'll go to opacity 0 and then we want
it to be
visibility hidden
but in order to make it still visibility
visible but opacity zero we're going to
add 99
so when the animation is almost done
it's going to be at
visibility visible but
opacity zero and then let's see if i
need to adjust any of these styles here
i guess i don't need this anymore
opacity or display none
i think this should work famous last
words
let's reload for good measure okay see
what happens
fades in all right oh my gosh it fades
out
yes uh i always feel so good when you're
like
struggling with something and you're
researching it and then finally get it
to work
that's an interesting little lesson i
guess like display
none is different from visibility hidden
versus
opacity zero and they all sort of do
different things okay
yay let's go back to the mobile view
here
oh i'm so happy oh this is great
okay so now that we have our nice
fade-in animation of the overlay
next step is to actually code the
menu
now to start off building this off
canvas menu looking at the design
we can see that it's fairly simple it's
just a white block and each link
is in its own row so what we're going to
do
is first write the html markup and then
i'm going to style it in our scss
and then the last step will be to handle
the animation and make it
slide on screen or fade in or something
when you
open the hamburger menu so let's go into
our code editor
and let's figure out where we want to
put the markup for
the menu so obviously we want to be in
the header tag since it is
part of the header the menu is so i'm
going to i think
put the menu in a div after the nav so
let's call
this header underscore underscore menu
maybe
wait am i using this already oh yeah i'm
using the menu
for the hamburger i think this is more
of the menu so i'm going to
rename what the hamburger is so instead
of underscore ownership menu let's make
it underscore underscore
toggle and then i'll just rename this in
these styles so
here we go header menus now header
toggle let's just do quick
find and replace here i'll just add a
little
toggle here to clarify what that's doing
let's double check the javascript as
well
it doesn't look like there's a menu so
we're good on that side
let's just go back to our site real
quick make sure everything's still
working
okay overlay and the hamburger icon are
still working which is good
so now let's move forward and create our
header menu the header menu is going to
be
you know that white block and then in
that we're going to make some
links so let's look back at the design
one two three four five links so we'll
say
a link times five again using that emit
shortcut
press enter and we got five links this
is just a landing page so i don't need
to have these actually be links
so it's gonna be home about contact blog
careers boom
about a boot contact
blog it's like a test of my short-term
memory and careers
let's just double check that all about
contact blog careers yay
i think this should be all the markup
that we need let's go back into the
header
and then add the styles for the menu
so the menu so the background is going
to be background will be
white did i create a variable for the
white color
the variables white i did it'll be
background
white and then in that will be links
and i don't think i need an additional
class for the anchor links themselves
it's just enough that they're anchor
links so that's going to be color
and looks like it's probably the same
gray as the
header here so let's go back into our
variables and
i'm guessing it's the dark blue thing
now we also need to add a bit of spacing
get my handy dandy little rectangle here
and then we will see first how much
spacing there is on the top
and bottom of the whole thing
this looks like about 36.
it's the same on the bottom and then
each link oh i need some space
too what i might do is do something like
this where each link is going to be a
certain height maybe 36
and then let me duplicate this square
here then i'll add
another padding on top and bottom of 26
so then each link is going to be
you know 36 something like this we can
always tweak it later on so it's gonna
be
padding of top and bottom is 26 and then
36
height for each link so padding
i guess i need to use a calculator again
36 no no 26 for the padding divided by
16 is 1.625 rems
1.625 rams on top and bottom and then 0
on left and right
i guess we just do it all around so we
got the padding and then i think i also
want to
now there's a couple ways you could do
this i could i could add
top and bottom padding to the link
itself i could also
add the height of 36 and then make it a
flexbox parent
and align items center i think i'm just
going to
add the top and bottom padding let's say
10 pixels on top and bottom
that way i don't have to write as many
styles as i would if i had to
turn this into a flexbox thing so
padding oops
padding and 10 going back to calculator
0.625
and what the heck we'll just make it all
the way around
now let's see what we got on our site
and we got our links
it has a white space but i think that's
okay so i want them to
not be side by side and it's happening
because anchor links
by default are display i think inline or
inline block
one of those if we change them to
display block then they will take up the
whole width
that they want that they can there we go
so display block maybe text align center
oops on the caps lock again text line
center
looks like that works so let's add those
styles into our code
display block and for whatever reason
i like to order my styles in
this way where text line
center where i start with the bigger
properties like display and position
flexbox things and then i move on to
margin and padding
and then i do text colors and then at
the end i'll do like transitions or
whatever
it's just a way that i like to keep
things a little bit organized because
when you start getting more rules you
don't want to be searching so i just try
to group these similar
styles together let's slow the site that
looks pretty good
now the other thing we need to look at
is this
white block for the menu doesn't take up
the entire
width but it looks like so you can see
on the mobile site
there's like a container width so you
have some space
on left and right and it looks like it's
kind of sort of the same
um all the way down let me refresh my
memory and see if i actually added some
padding to stuff
okay i did added some padding and that's
from header nav so it's just kind of a
global padding thing
okay so before i do more stuff with the
menu itself
i think i need to add some add this
padding that i have here on the header
and put it
sort of for anything on the mobile page
because
we want we don't want things to go all
the way to the edge and it looks like
things are right now because yeah like
later on
we're gonna need that padding the
padding that i was looking at was on the
nav
okay i think the best way to do this is
to take this padding
not have it nav specific but make it a
helper class of course
so let's add some spacing
so we'll say the generic container
class and then this will have the
padding so that means
we want to go into the nav element and
then
add the container padding there okay
looks like it's working
so it doesn't have the padding in the
nav but it's in the
container class so now that means we can
add this container class to other
other elements but actually for the
container class i only want the left
and right padding i don't want the top
and bottom so i think what i'm going to
do
is take this top and bottom make it zero
for the
container upper class but go back to the
header and put the
nav selector back and say padding
1.0625 rams zero because
oh boy what did i do oh i know why
it's because this reset the padding so
the nav has the padding
just on top and bottom and it's
cancelling out the left and right
padding
here and that's because i'm using this
padding shorthand so the best way to do
this
is to specify padding top
and padding bottom i use a little
control d to duplicate the line
so it's a really helpful shortcut here
and then
here it's going to be padding left and
right
of 1.5 rims there we go
shorthand properties are great but
sometimes you do want to split them out
just because you might want different
values for different elements so now
the nav has padding all the way across
which is good and we can start adding
the container class padding to other
elements when we have the menu open
we want it to be on top of the
overlay and then have that spacing so i
think if i just add the container class
to the header menu itself
should automatically do that we can't
see it right now but
there we go so we can see there is
padding there although wait a minute
i don't want padding i want margin for
that
so i'm going to keep the padding because
i do need it for like the other content
down on the page
but we need to change this padding to
margin for just the header
menu so let's get rid of this
and let's take that padding left and
right it's 1.5 rems
we do want it to match the padding that
the rest of the container elements are
going to have
but we're going to make it a margin
instead
so margin and i think we can use the
shorthand so 0 and then 1.5 rims
so now you can see that it does have
that margin you just can't see it on the
page itself because everything's white
so i think we should be good to go now
let's just take one more look at the
design
okay so there are some rounded corners
let's add a border radius to
the menu as well border radius
let's try three pixels i think we have
enough now that we can start
doing the overlay thing right now the
header menu
is under the overlay because the overlay
as i'm assuming it has a z index
maybe it doesn't have z index because i
didn't do it yet let's see what we got
here
overlay and then nav is there
menu's under that i guess because this
doesn't have a z index
set and that is probably because there's
no position property
so if you don't have a position property
it's going to default to position static
which
means that anything that has its
position set or has a z-index value is
going to be on top of it so let's see
what happens if we add position
absolute okay so now it's on top of
stuff and let's try with 100
you can see it's like going off the
screen so what we want to do
is this margin thing isn't actually
doing anything so it's positioned
absolute
what you could do is instead of with 100
you could say with like 90
and then margin actually i don't know if
it's going to work because it's position
absolute
yeah it's not so since it's positioned
absolute unfortunately you can't use the
margin auto on left and right
to center it because it's like not in
relation to anything else it's absolute
now i do want to make that spacing right
so since we had that margin before of
1.5 rams which is not being used
obviously
i don't know if it's the best way but i
can do a calc and say i want this to be
all the way across 100
minus 1.5 rams on either side so 1.5
times 2 is 3 so 3 rims then when we
center it it'll be
it'll sort of be flushed to either side
for the container
for position absolute element you can
center it by using
left 50 and then trans
form translate x
negative 50 and what this is doing is
left 50
is making it go 50 or halfway across
you know its container so that's why
it's right in the middle what transform
does
is it's going to let me turn off that
left if you don't have it by default
it's going to be left aligned right
so if you turn on transform translate x
you're moving it
50 of the object itself so not the
container but the object itself
so that's why combining the left
so this is the middle line right here
and we want to move it back to be
centered
we only want to move it back this much
half of the width of the
element itself so that's why these
combined will give you a centered
position absolute item so let's do this
we're going to copy these things
over to our code there we go
so position absolute width is the calc
hundred percent my three rims
to have the padding and doing the left
50 transform translate x
negative 50. i think i need to get rid
of this margin yeah there we go
don't need that anymore opening the
overlay now we can see it's nicely
centered
and we probably need a little bit of
space on the top there using our little
handy dandy
rectangle here let's see how much space
that is about
24 so we are going to do margin
top where's the calculator
24 divided by 16. 1.5
there we go okay so now looks pretty
good
i think i might need a little bit more
rounded corners let's try increasing
that border radius a little bit
maybe five i compared the design
it's actually not super round i think
five is good
okay so there we have our mobile menu
the next thing we need to do is we want
to animate the menu on screen
when the menu's closed is going to be
off canvas meaning off
you know your viewport you're not going
to be able to see it and then it'll
somehow animate in
we could either fade it in we could
slide it down from the top or slide it
in
from the right let's do some research so
go back to codepen search for off canvas
menu maybe
maybe mobile menu maybe animated mobile
menu
get a little more specific okay
responsive menu with icon
this seems pretty popular so i'm just
kind of getting ideas for
you know how they're handling this thing
um where's the menu
what no well not sure what happened to
that
bootstrap 4 animated menu you click this
thing
so this is interesting it sort of fades
in covers everything so that's that's
one way we could do it sort of similar
to the
how the overlay sort of fades into fades
out you could fade in the menu
along with the overlay so that would
actually be sort of cool
i think i'm going to do that i was
thinking i was going to slide in from
the left or right but
fading in actually seems quite nice and
we can hopefully
utilize some of the same styles and
animations that we did for the overlay
into the menu so looking again the
overlay
was set at opacity zero position fixed
is that right
wait a minute it's opacity zero it's
still
you can't click through it so it is here
oh yeah it's not clickable what did i do
i think i forgot to
maybe add visibility hidden
then we can still select stuff
underneath it yeah
i just needed to add that visibility
hidden and actually i
since i'm reusing this for the overlay
and also the menu
let's make it a helper class like
everything else so let's see
here visibility maybe i should put it in
animations
so we're using visibility so what i'm
gonna do is before the keyframes i'm
going to add another helper class
i'll say has fade
and i'll say visibility hidden and
that's gonna be the default state of
any of these elements that we're fading
in and fading fading out let's see
go to header okay it doesn't have
visibility here because i had forgotten
it last time
but now i can add the has fade class
to the overlay and if this works we'll
also add it to
our menu itself let's reload for a good
measure okay so overlay has
fade visibility is hidden i can see that
i can
select through like the overlay is not
preventing me from clicking here because
it's the text cursor okay so this is
working so i'm going to add that has
fade
class also to the menu itself so header
menu
has fade so now it's not visible
because it is visibility hidden let's
find the element there it is
so has fade so now i can just kind of do
the same thing that i did
for the overlay in our javascript
scoot this over a little bit so we can
see our javascripts
we are when we open the hamburger menu
we are
adding the fade in fade out to the
overlay we also want to do that to the
menu
but since they both have that has faith
class what i could do
is instead of having to duplicate
both these lines of code for both
elements i could say
const i'll just say fade elements
elements so document query selector
and then if it has that class of has
fade
i can hopefully target it with this
actually i might need query selector oh
yeah because query selector i think will
just yeah it just gets the first one so
i need to do query selector all
that's why i'm naming the constant name
with a plural instead of a singular
just little little hints like that will
sort of help you not make mistakes so
let's handle the open stuff first
fade elements and i think you can do
four
each for each
all right i can't remember the syntax uh
javascript
for each i know this is very basic
i admit i'm not super
well versed in javascript
here we go oh yeah for each function
yada yada
so for each function we want to
do this so then in the function it's
going to be element
hopefully this will work okay so what we
want to happen
is on both the overlay and the header
menu when we click this we want it to
add the fade in class
ooh it worked um what happened here
weird it's disappearing for some strange
reason
what happened maybe let me try removing
the has fade class from the menu
just to see what happens when it's only
on the overlay
weird why is it disappearing like that
that's very strange
let me try to do it manually fade in oh
even if i do it manually weird
something about the has fade is like
canceling this for some reason because i
have the visibility hidden
okay let's start from the beginning
adding the class via javascript does
seem to be working so that's not the
problem
the problem seems to be because of this
has fade class
where i set the visibility to hidden oh
it's because
i think i didn't add the end state for
this visibility visible
there we go i think that should work now
yeah because
the way i'm running the animation it's
going forward so it's keeping the end
state here
so because this was not here it kind of
defaulted back to the visibility hidden
from that has fade class
so now things should work let's see
okay stays like that okay so let's add
the has fade class back to the
header menu
all right oh i didn't add the other
stuff we just added code for the fade in
which seems to be working looks pretty
nice might speed that animation up a
little bit
so let's do the reverse so do the same
thing
fade elements for each
function element so the element
parameter
because it's looping through every
element that has the has fade class
you can use the element parameter to
target and run functions and stuff like
that
so element element
okay so now both the open and close
functionality should work
so let's give it a run
hey look at that nice okay i'm gonna
speed that up a bit it's just a little
bit
a little bit slow so let's do 200
for both fade in and fade out but i'm
pretty pleased how this looks
i think that's pretty good now i did
want to fix that overlay because when
you scroll like this
like the overlay is not going all the
way to the top
overlay i said top 3.75
how about zero oh it's because i don't
want it to be on top of the header
or i don't want it to be on top of the
nav i want the header to be on top of it
but i think that adding
it should still go all the way to the
top so i think it's because this doesn't
have a position set
i think this is position relative i'm
trying to put the nav on top of the
overlay
oh it doesn't have a background color it
was just using it from the um
the body but it needs its own background
color there we go
so now still scrolls and stuff let's do
that so to the nav we'll add position
relative
and the background color
relative background color
white all right
there we go now oh i forgot to
rest remove the overlay thing top of
zero
to reload here we go now
you know this looks pretty good another
thing people do sometimes
is when you open the menu you sort of
lock scrolling on the body so
you basically say overflow hidden so
then you can't scroll
so i think i might do that with yet
another helper class
so body what another class of this we'll
just say
no scroll so overflow
hidden we are going to have to add this
class to the body
when you open the menu so when you open
the menu we're going to
oh i need to add it as a constant let's
add it to the
top here constant body equals document
query selector body
there we go when you open it you're
going to
lock the scroll by adding this class
list
add no scroll and
then we'll do the reverse
remove and we'll just put this one first
since that's the way we had it in the
other one
let's see if this works so opening the
menu
all right so we can't scroll i'm trying
to scroll and it's not happening because
it wants to keep you on the menu
when i close the menu removes no scroll
class and we can again
scroll down okay hey this is turning out
to be
pretty good so we're done with the
mobile menu and the next step is going
to be
going back and adding the rest of the
content of the site
all right now before we start any coding
of course we want to look back at the
design
and just have an idea of where we're
going with this and how we want things
to look
on mobile and desktop so looking at the
design the hero section on mobile is
stacked to one column with the image on
top and then the copy and button
below that then on desktop we have two
columns instead of one column with the
text
on the left and then the image on the
right you might also notice that the
images on the hero are slightly
different between mobile and desktop
so let's look at our files and see how
that is going to be set up
i have open here my project folder
with all the website files and i already
had saved all the images from front
mentor in this images subfolder
so my guess is the background intro
desktop is going to be this one
yep and then we got one from mobile this
is just that
designed background we need to look for
the images of the phones
probably this image mockups here what
this is is a png with a transparent
background
and we can overlay that same image of
the phones over
the mobile background from mobile and
then the desktop background going back
to the design one more time
we can probably use the same markup for
both mobile and desktop and then we'll
use styles to
differentiate the styles between mobile
and desktop as well
so let's get started going into our code
editor vs code
and we're going to add markup for our
hero section so i'm going to create a
section tag
and i'm going to call it class of hero
underscore underscore
just hero actually then in the hero
section tag we'll add a div
of class i'll start with the image so
hero underscore underscore image
and under that we'll do div class hero
underscore underscore
we'll just say text up in the hero image
is going to be the image
with the phones and the background and
then the hero text is going to be under
that
and i'm doing it this way because on
mobile we have the image first
and then the copy so then we can just
change the style so that the image is
going to be on the right for
desktop so now let's go into our
files from front of mentor and we want
to copy over the
text that they gave us so we don't have
to like type it out manually
when you download the files from front
of mentor they give you an index.html
file
with all the text already there so i'm
just going to copy and paste that over
so
hero title is next generation digital
banking
now let me figure out what html tag we
want to use
so usually on a website the h1 tag is
going to be the name of the page
but i've also seen it where for a home
page you use an h1 tag for the hero
title
and then why choose easy bank would be
h2 latest articles would be h2 and so on
and then we would do h3 tags for these
little subtitles here for each section
so yeah i think i'm going to do next
generation digital banking is going to
be the h1 tag
we'll do that h1 and it doesn't need a
class since there's just gonna be one of
these then we'll copy over this
text sorry this goes in the text hero
section
there we go and then i'm also going to
add the button
and let's kind of look back and see what
i had done before
or like this request invite button up in
the header you just look for request
invite there we go so i did an anchor
tag with this button class
and then a header cta class so let's do
the same thing here we'll just use an
anchor tag and let's say it's an anchor
link
we'll just do a round and we'll give it
a class
of hero cta but we also need a class of
buttons so it takes all those button
styles that we had
built in the previous videos request
invite is the text in that button so
let's do that
and i think i'm forgetting the yeah
there's some subtitle stuff here
this is an h1 i think because this is
longer it's not really a subtitle
i'm just going to put it in a paragraph
tag and
i don't think i need to put a class on
that because we can just use the hero
text
paragraph tag selector so let's just do
that copy this text over
here we go oh wait i had already copied
this so i actually don't need this file
open anymore okay so i'll just delete
this since we don't need it anymore
okay so now if we look at our site you
can see that we have
the button styles have already gotten
ported over which is great
and then the next thing we want to do is
we want to figure out how we want to
code the hero image what i think i want
to do
is i'm going to create a div and we also
need to keep in mind that on desktop you
can see this phone image
on the right kind of overhangs the
section because next section
has this really light gray background my
guess is that
this phone image is going to need to be
absolutely positioned
you can sort of guess something needs to
be absolutely positioned if it's like on
top of something else so because
the phone image is on top of the next
section
over sort of overhanging it a little bit
we can guess that this needs to be
absolutely positioned there's a couple
ways you could do this you could
create a separate div just for the
images which
you know obviously i have the hero image
div you could also
use maybe pseudo elements and then have
that absolutely positioned so what i
think i'm going to do is
in the hero image itself is where i'm
going to put
the background image that svg sort of
designed background
and then maybe i'll store the phone
images
in a pseudo class or pseudo-element like
before pseudoelement
so let's try that so in that case we
actually don't need to add any more
markup to the hero image because
everything's going to be added
in the styles let's move on to adding
our styles
so in our app folder i just need to make
sure that i'm writing the styles in the
correct place
and since this hero section is a new
section and it kind of is
by itself let's create a new sas file so
create
new file we'll call this hero.scss
and of course we need to add the
file importing importing it into our
main sas file so we can just close that
for now
and then in the hero section just move
it over to the right side so we can
sort of see our markup and our styles at
the same time
we'll add a selector of hero then i'm
just going to add the
ampersand underscore underscore image
ampersand underscore underscore text so
let's start with the
mobile styles first so in the hero image
selector i want to say background
image url and we're going to
load that so in the images folder you
want to load
the background intro
mobile now we also want to add some
other background
style rules so background size we're
going to say cover
i do that so that you kind of keep the
correct aspect ratio of the image and it
doesn't you know stretch it or whatever
but also it'll fill the space then
background repeat
no repeat because we don't want it to
repeat and then just for good measure i
usually do background position
we'll just do center center so it is
centered in the div
now let's see what that looks like in
our browser
okay it doesn't look like anything and
the reason for that is probably because
there is no actual content in the hero
image tag so you can see
that there are the styles there the
background image is showing up
but because there's no height it is not
going to
show up at all so we need to do is
figure out how tall we want this div to
be and we'll sort of add that in the
styles as well
i'm going to grab my little handy dandy
rectangle here maybe we'll zoom in a
little bit on the
mobile design i'm just gonna figure out
how tall
of roughly do i want this div to be so
it's about 282 so maybe we'll say
280 pixels so let's say for
mobile min height
is 280 pixels and then i'm going to
convert
that to rems by dividing 280 pixels by
16.
16 is the base font size so you get 17.5
rams now let's take another look at our
website oh
there we go so it did now show up now
this is a little bit wider than mobile
of course so maybe i'll just turn on the
mobile emulator
in my browser so this looks closer to
what we want in the design
zoom out a little bit so you can see
here we got the background going so now
we just need to add in
the image of those phones and i decided
to do that
in a before pseudo element
with a background image it doesn't work
we can try something else like using an
actual image tag
you know there's almost always more than
one way of
building anything so you don't need to
worry too much about
finding the one perfect way as long as
it is as simple as possible
and it is understandable for yourself in
the future or another dev to look at the
code and understand how it works
then i think that you can choose any
approach that makes the most sense to
you
the image is image mockups we'll kind of
do the same thing where
we're going to do the background size
cover and these other background
properties
the other thing we want to do is we want
to do position
absolute since we're going to do that
later on and because
this is position absolute we have to
make sure that the parent of the before
pseudo element which is the hero
image selector is position relative
otherwise this image is going to
basically
basically fly up out of where you want
it to be so just make sure that when you
position absolute you make
the parent a position relative to keep
it sort of within the balance of the
parent
so let's just see what this looks like
now look like anything
this is probably again because oh i
forgot
so when you have a before or an after
pseudo element you need to
give it a content property otherwise it
will just not even exist on the page
this is just a characteristic of using
these pseudo elements
okay so now we can see in our inspector
before is there
so i think what i want to do is maybe
add the
height and i'm going to set height to
100 so that it will match the height of
the parent so let's save that
and what's going on oh there's no width
here
so when something's not showing up or
doing what you want to do
it's really good idea to always check in
your code inspector
i'm just trying to figure out and
troubleshoot what is causing the issue
so right now the issue we're looking at
is why is the phone image not showing up
look at this before element i can see
that it has zero
width but it does have 280 height
because i set the height property
so we're also going to set the width to
100
percent and we'll see how that looks
okay so now we got our phones they are
not quite the right
size i think looking at this we want the
bottom of that phone
to perfectly align with the bottom of
the background and that is not what's
happening here this is the bottom of the
background
and just for good measure and debugging
i often like to do this
so i'll do a temporary border one pixel
solid
let's do magenta adding a border will
sort of tweak the size of the
div but for most cases i think it's
still okay
now we see we have a border of the hero
image and we have the background going
down there
but we want the phones to end on the
bottom we don't want it to be centered
like it is right now so what we want to
do is
adjust the background position so it
aligns from the bottom
for center center this is the center
horizontally is the first center
second center is the vertical center
instead of center for vertical we're
going to say we want to
position itself at the bottom so now we
can see that the image kind of ends
right at the bottom
of that hero image div now looking back
at the design
i think the phone images are a little
bit yeah it looks like they're a little
bit smaller than what we have in our
website
there's just a little bit more space on
left and right so let's go
and sort of adjust that a little bit so
the phone images are in the
pseudo element the before element so how
do we make this
narrower what we could do there's a
couple ways right now the width is 100
so if you decrease that
um it would sort of decrease but then
you have a case where
it's not centered so then you'd have to
add like a margin
auto weight display block maybe oh
because it's absolutely
oh that would be too annoying you have
to do left 50
transform translate x
negative 50 to center it that's a little
bit too much
so i'm just going to delete those the
better way i think
is to keep the width at 100 so it's
still 100 of the width of the parent
but in background size instead of cover
cover will basically ensure that
the image is going to cover the entire
div so
even if it means cutting off from the
sides it'll make sure that it covers
everything that's usually what we want
for things like this but
because i want to make it a little bit
smaller so we can
also use percentages in background size
so if you say 100
it's going to looks like pretty close to
cover
yes just basically 100 of the div so if
we reduce that
then maybe down to 94 it's reducing the
background
size but it is still centered because
the width is at 100
and then we set background position to
center for the horizontal
so we'll just adjust that background
size so maybe 93
for that before element so background
size 93
reload for good measure that looks wait
now the bottom isn't matching
oh i forgot to save the center bottom
let's do that
there we go now it is pretty much close
to the bottom not perfectly but i think
that's okay we'll just sort of live with
the imperfection
and then it is kind of in from the sides
a little bit so that looks pretty good
now the next thing we're going to look
at is the copy for the hero section
so let's look at the design and
obviously it looks a little bit
different than what we got here on our
website so it looks like we need to
make sure the font is the right font
family
also the color needs to be a bit
different let's just start with this
title next generation digital banking
i believe the font family itself should
be the same as
some of the title fonts that we have
let's check out our style guide just to
make sure what we're doing okay so font
family we just are using public sands
for everything
weight 300 and 400 300 is light 400 is
regular
the font still looks still slightly off
let's just check this out
this pull extends so maybe we just need
to make the font size bigger
get this let's get a rectangle here and
it's going to try to
guesstimate what size the font is 30
pixels
tall looks like font size 30 pixels
the font weight seems a lot different in
the design
you know what i mean like it looks a lot
more thin seems like that's the font
that we're using
and 30 pixels looks different as well
okay so maybe 30 pixels is right but
maybe the font weight
is not correct that's 300 what does 400
look like
doesn't look any different for some
reason the
h1 oh i bet it's because the
h1 tag it's not going to show this here
but usually
the browser default will set all font
weights to bold
so font weight here we go 300 now that
looks a bit closer to
the weight in the design going back to
our hero
bass file so in the hero text section
we'll add another selector for h1
and we'll say font weight is 300 and
font family has already been chosen in
the
global fast file everything is public
stands i'm just going to close this
animation this thing too
all you do here is the want weight of
300 and then the
color is this sort of dark blue
so in our variables last file it's this
dark blue
variable and we'll say color dark blue
and usually what i do for headline tags
is i'm going to
add a line of about one i'll just put it
in the h1 tag
line height one usually
for headline tags title tags you want
the line height to be
around one maybe slightly bigger and
then when you have body copy like
paragraphs where you have like longer
longer amounts of text then you want the
line to be a bit greater than that like
1.3 or 1.5
depending on the design font size i
think i said was
30. let's get the calculator out 30
divided by
16 is 1.875
1.875 grams much closer
to what we want here i think maybe 30
might not be big enough
actually that's 37
size 37 pixels going back here
okay that looks much closer in size i
think i need to increase the line height
a little bit
maybe 1.1 maybe 1.2
a little bit less let's do 1.15 just
kind of meet in the middle there
all right so let's copy these styles
over so i think i said font size was
37 pixels i need to convert that 37
divided by 16 is 2.31
just round a little bit here and then
line height was i think 1.15
all right and we need to center the text
here
it seems like most of the content on
mobile is centered
so i think maybe for now i'll just set
text align center
for the entire hero section hero text we
can do there
text align center and then we'll change
it to
left align for the desktop media query
there we go
so going back to the hero let's add the
selector for the
paragraph in the text hero text area
and we'll say line height and i'm not
sure if this is right yet but maybe 1.5
to start off
and it's going to be inheriting the font
size of 14 pixels
facing looks okay and we also need to
figure out some of the spacing
under the headline to the paragraph so
this is something like 24
and then under the paragraph above the
button so maybe something like 37 or 36
so 24 space under the headline 36
space under the paragraph itself so h1
by default will inherit the styles in
the browser which we don't necessarily
want
i want to basically take out this top
margin
that just gets added to the headline
tags i usually try to
add space between elements by adding
margin to the bottom of things
not to the top here headline tags so
we'll say
h1 h2 h3 margin top
of zero there we go now i'm gonna go
back here
now it's all the way up to the top a lot
of spacing in the hero text
area itself but for the margin bottom
right now it's about 30
and i think it was 24 so under the hero
margin bottom 24 divided by 16
1.5 rams and then in the paragraph we're
adding a margin bottom
of i think was 36 pixels divided by 16
2.25 rims
now looks a bit closer to our design eh
so there's space between the paragraph
and the button now which is pretty good
i need to figure out the space above the
headline
and to the end of the thing so it
actually looks pretty similar to 36
so 36 on the top on the bottom it's all
the way up to 87.
so i think what i want to do is ideally
at least
in my mind you would probably want the
same amount of space at the top and
bottom
of each section so this space here
should be the same
amount of space as up to here 85 seems
like a little bit but i think
we'll do maybe 60 pixels as kind of like
the wrapper
that way i can put it in a helper class
which means i can then just add the
wrapper class
to each section that i want to add that
space
and so we kind of make our styles a
little bit more consistent
and a little bit simpler all right so i
said container
padding left and padding right as you
can see here
container has has padding of 24 on the
left and the right
so i had padding top and bottom just for
the nav and then
i had added padding left and right for
the container and that is equal to 24.
let's do that first the left and the
right spacing by adding that container
class
and then we'll move on to adding the top
and bottom spacing so
hero text i think maybe let's just see
if we can do that there
container and then go back to our
website and now
you can see here the hero text has this
space
and i didn't want to do it on the hero
image because that one kind of goes
to the full left and right let's see if
i add a container then
it kind of messes up the alignment that
i had going
okay so now i've got the hero text it
has a padding on left and right which is
good
kind of matches what we have here with
the image of the phone
so now i'm going to think of a way of
creating that top and bottom spacing
with
a helper class you know do i want to add
it to the container
or do i want to add it somewhere else
because
not everything wants to have that top
and bottom padding
i'd only use the container thing in the
nav
so i wonder if in the container i could
add padding top and bottom of
i think i said 60. let's think about
this if i add it to the container
that would be good for this because then
it has a space on top and bottom and
left and right
but then it would also take effect in a
nav and i don't want that
let's just add it to the container and
see
where you know kind of breaks the design
so 2.25 rims
i'll do the same thing for bottom
you might do the same thing as me but
when i'm going around for adding
padding or margin i always start from
the top actually right should be next
top right bottom and left is last
let's just check on that now and see how
this looks
so going to our rules you can see
header nav it has a padding top and
bottom which i had set previously which
is good
if we scroll down to the container you
can see that did have the padding top
and padding bottom of 2.25 rem
but that got overridden by the more
specific rule
of header nav this is because
using the class of header within the
child nav is more specific than the
just the general class of container just
curious what if i do header
container okay so in that case that
would be more specific
probably because the first rule is using
the class of header and then the element
of nav
whereas the class of header and class
container class is more specific than
the element itself that's why this would
override
the class header nav selector so it's
almost like rock paper scissors
class beats element selector but then id
selector will be
class selector it's just something that
is good to know when you're working with
css a lot
looks like we have our container stuff
all set go back to our mobile view and
just kind of double check on that
things look a little better right we're
getting more spacing added we spacing on
top and bottom
and we have this see the buttons kind of
going into
the bottom padding i believe that's
because
i probably need to set display
inline block because i think by default
if i don't say anything it's just going
to be
an anchor tag is going to be display
inline so making it display block will
make it have to
follow the the rules that i've set for
padding and stuff so now you can see
having set display in line block the
button is now inside the content
and not going into the padding wait and
that's in the header
i might need to move the button rolls
out of the header sas
file just because there's places outside
of the header that are using
the buttons let's do display inline
block
at the top so now this actually looks
pretty good
we got our hero section from mobile
looks like everything is good in terms
of spacing
got our button going click the hover
state's not working on that
you see i have that hover state on the
top let's see where those rules are
coming from make sure that they get
applied to all buttons
so in the inspector i'm going to select
that top header button
click on the hover and if you check this
hover box it'll sort of force
the hover state so you can see which
style rules
are getting applied so it looks like
yeah the hover
is part of the header cta rules and i
want that to be
applied to any button so let's go into
our header sas file that was under the
cta
so font size font small so
i wonder if i need to make the font size
and color in the button itself
so i think what i'm going to do is i'm
going to let me move this globals over
here
what i want to do is i'm going to take
the font size from the cta the header ct
button and put it in the
global button rules let's just do it
down here
font size and then the color is white
it's already set there so i don't really
need that
this can also also just be copied over
so i'm just going to delete this header
cta
now all the styles that we need are
going to apply to all buttons since
we're saving it in the global sas
file let's try this again now we can see
the hero button has that nice little
hover state you don't always have to
write your styles perfectly the first
time because a lot of things you just
kind of figure out as you build
the website there's always going to be
going back and sort of correcting things
and tweaking things depending on
issues that come up as you're building
out this website there's nothing at all
wrong with
going back and changing your work a
little bit now that we have our mobile
styles for the hero let's add the
desktop styles
going back to our design you can see
that the hero was one column
on mobile with the image first then the
text on desktop
it is two columns with the text on the
left and the image on the right
so we're going to do is add some flexbox
to this what i want to do is
in the hero selector add display
flex to turn on flexbox but i only want
this rule
to take effect for desktop widths and up
what i've done
before was i created a mixins sas file
and we have our breakpoint up mixin that
i can then use
to add the media query so we'll say
include breakpoint dash
up and in the parameters the size we
want to hit we're going to focus on the
large
and up then i can move this rule
into the breakpoint media query so just
by adding this one rule let's look at
our website and see how that looks
for desktop okay so you can probably
guess what's happening here the
hero image doesn't have any height but
we can see that flexbox is turned on
there we go flex 1 and we'll add flex 1
to the
hero text as well this is just to start
off
to kind of make both of them the same
amount of space
but you can see that let's add that flex
of one
in the desktop width to both the image
and the text
selectors so we'll say flex
of one and we'll change this later on
but we just kind of want to get things
started
now we can see that there is height
because adding the flux of one that
makes the
child flex element be the same height
across
both of the flex child elements you
notice in the design the
image is on the right for the desktop
but because
in the market we added hero image first
that's why it's on the left
so that's another thing you can do in
flexbox is you can adjust the order
so we want the image to be
second on desktop i think it's flex
order
it's just order and we want to be two so
we want to be second
and we want text to be first so order of
one
there we go second thing we need to do
is look at the
heights because this looks like it's not
quite tall enough compared to the design
so on desktop the hero image is about
and we're not going to take into
consideration this overhang here because
the section itself
ends just about down here the
pixels tall there's a couple ways we can
do that we can of course adjust the hero
section itself to be 655 pixels tall or
we can make the image
655 pixels tall and then we know that
the text will sort of take the same
height so hero image
what happens if we say height of 655
pixels
so now we can see that it is taking up
more space which is what we want
so let's just say minimum height for
desktop
and that's 655 divided by 16 to get 40
let's just say 41 rems
it doesn't need to be perfectly exact
but going back here
so now it's taller we do want to center
the text
we want to center the content in the
flexbox in the flexbox parent in the
hero flexbox parent
you can say align items enter
this will automatically vertically align
everything so now of course what we need
to do is we need to make this hero image
the height of the
parent hero do that by in the desktop
breakpoint
say height is 100 so we'll take the
height of the parent
hmm let's see let's see let's see i bet
it's because
in flexbox it's kind of intelligent so
it'll size things
based on the content and because the
image has no content it's really
looking to the hero text element for the
height so i think actually i do need to
move
the height from the hero parent selector
to the hero image
let's try this just say height okay so
there we go
this is a little more like what we're
hoping it'll look like i'm gonna get rid
of that magenta
outline i don't really need that anymore
now we're getting there right
texas centered on the left we've got our
image on the right the height is
pretty much what we want now we need to
make sure
the image is correct because you
remember we had two different ones
here we go right now it's just loading
the mobile one and get another
media query and then for the image i'll
say background intro
probably desktop so now it's loading the
desktop
so let's check on the design again looks
like the phone sort of starts
here kind of toward the end of that blue
little wavy section
so we need to move that background over
a little bit so we can see the end
we'll adjust the background position
because right now it's just centered
i'm just testing it in the browser it's
a little bit quicker that way
horizontally i really want it to
start from the left side of that
background image so we'll say left
center we'll center it vertically so
this is actually a little bit the
phone's a bit
down from the top of that gray blue
section so
what happens if we do bottom
of it left top oh actually i think we
can leave it left center
but what we want to do is adjust the
mock-up so that they're
down so we can do something like top 10
or something then at least it's going to
be a little bit closer to being under
there
and we also looks like we want to move
it over a little bit
but let's just focus on this background
stuff right now and
copy over the style so that i don't
forget what i did the background
position left center
for desktop for hero image image desktop
new background image and now it's also
going to have a new background position
that looks pretty good we'll adjust how
the phones are positioned over the
background image
after we make it the right width because
right now this is 50
and then the image is 50 but in reality
there's more s width given to the images
so now we're going to do is going to go
back into our hero section
sas file and we're going to adjust the
flex child
properties the first one was image and
the image one was a wider one so we'll
set that flex of three
then for the text it's going to be two
so what these numbers mean
is the available space in the parent
gets allotted to each child
it's kind of like a ratio image is going
to get three parts and then the text is
going to get two parts
okay so it looks a little bit closer to
the design right so there's more
more space given for the image and then
a little bit less space for the
for the text now i think i also need to
make sure that we're using that
container to
have a max width set because right now
everything is just going across so this
is 1240.
oh yeah it's going all the way across so
what i think i need to do is for the
container helper class which i already
added which is good
i'm going to have to add a max width let
me just show you what that will look
like
max width and i think it was 11 13
pixels
and then we're going to have a margin of
auto
it'll center it so then anything with
the container helper class is going to
have a max width
set and then it'll be centered if the
width is larger than that
going back to our code editor and i
believe it's in our globals
so max width is going to be i said 11
13 just according to the design maybe
we'll round it down 11 10
and turn into around 69.375
grams and then margin of zero on top and
bottom and then auto left and right and
that will center
the container now we go back to here so
we can see the header now is centered
nicely it's limited to that 11 110
and then we're going to add that
container class to the hero as well
this is going to be tricky because i use
the container class in the hero text
to add that padding for the mobile
styles but i think
if i just add the container class to the
hero itself
hopefully the padding on the left and
right should stay from mobile
let's just go back to mobile styles and
make sure
that we have the spacing that we wanted
here there's two things we want to do we
want to control the max width to have
that container but then we also want to
add
padding around the sections what we
could do
is i could split it out into two
different helper classes like a
container class and then
wrapper or some other generic word like
that or
i could add some modifiers to the
container class where
i could add padding and then add the
that special
modifier clasp sounds pretty good let's
try that if you just have a container
the most important thing i want to do is
to have that max width in the auto
margin
keeping in mind that there are cases
that i want to
only add padding to one side or maybe i
wanted to add to all sides except for
the top what if i did something like
adding modifier where it's container
padding top and then if you have that
it gets the padding top and i can do the
same thing
there we go so now we have the padding
but there might be cases where
i want the padding all the way around
might be cases where i just want it
maybe
top and bottom or just left and right so
i think i'll create maybe two more
helper
class modifiers where it's padding
just top and bottom let's just say
padding y that's kind of the vertical
axis and then for that we'll add
adding top and padding bottom
and then if i want padding only on the
left and right we'll save padding
x for horizontal then we'll add padding
adding right and adding left
it looks like i'm taking up a lot of
space by creating these extra classes
but it'll save me time when i'm creating
the markup later on
because now let me show you what i can
do for the
the header i want padding all the way
around so i can say
maybe i should add one more helper class
where it's
p all and then this one is going to have
everything
all the options so now i know it says
pal
we can now add container p-a-l-l
to the nav and then for the hero we can
say
container p
x let's see the hero container
actually didn't want any padding on this
at all now it's like this
change that okay hero container
now this is good there's no padding here
i need to add padding to the hero text
so what i could do there is a
container maybe padding all because it's
in the text element
here we go now we got container padding
all
this is good too because i'm not adding
the max width
rule to this element it won't hurt
anything it won't break the side but
it's just not really needed
i'm pretty happy with this but then
let's check out on desktop
we got hero container which is fine and
then the header
if you look in the nav it has a
container max width set and then it has
the
padding all the way around which is
perfect
all right i had to adjust the lighting
there because as i was recording the
last video someone was kind of going
down so things were just getting
darker and darker but now we should be
all set so
back in our hero section um i think the
next thing we want to do is
let's fix the hero text styles because i
think in the design
it is left aligned as opposed to being
centered like it is here let's go into
our hero styles
and here we go so text text line center
is what we set as a default mobile style
styles that's kind of
an example of mobile first styles where
your mobile styles are the default
styles
without any media queries and then you
add on
your desktop and so on styles using a
media query
you how that looks and there we go but i
wonder if
the text styles are bigger on desktop
perhaps
oh yeah definitely bigger i think before
it was maybe 37 is that right
37 yeah let's estimate what the desktop
h1 font size is going to be 40
52 let's try 52 font medium
well i guess we'll just add font maybe x
large
just in case we need something between
18 and 52.
so 52 divided by 16 is 3.25
so now for the the hero text section
h1 we want to add include
breakpoint up large and font size
is going to be that font x large so
there we go
and that looks more close to the design
where the line breaks
at next generation and then digital
banking's on the next line
let's just while we're at it double
check our body copy here so it looks
like it's a little bigger on desktop as
well
let's see how big this is going to be
for desktop
i think it's about maybe 20
maybe 19. let's just say 20. yes
font oh boy medium maybe large
for 20 pixels 20 divided by 16 is 1.25
that was for the body that's in the
global sas file here we go so
font size font small add or include
break point up
[Music]
orange font size
font large looks pretty good
looks smaller on the design let's take
that down to maybe
you know let's just try 18 since i
already have that variable saved
that looks pretty close to the design
i'm happy with that
now i need to tackle the more tricky
part which is this hero image section
the problem with this is that we want
the hero content to have that container
right so the max width is set
but for the hero image we actually want
this to go outside
of the container oh also the image goes
all the way up to the top of the
um header and actually oh my gosh
it looks like because the headers white
but then this hero background
i thought it was white but it actually
looks like a very very very light
gray that's pretty subtle okay so they
did have that
already set which is great so i think i
can just add it to the hero
selector i'm assuming we want that for
mobile as well
background color very light gray
okay so now it's very light gray but now
you can see here we have this problem
where
the container is limiting the width so
the gray's not going all the way out
i think i still will have to add the
container class
to a child of the hero container or just
of the hero rather
so it will be something like this class
equals container
and that container will move the hero
image and the hero text
divs kind of like this now going back
into our browser
oops i need to add the flexbox stuff
like flex
oh this is a problem so the flex styles
you want to put that in um hero
container
okay so now it looks better let's just
double check that looks okay on mobile
that looks okay okay so we'll go back to
desktop
now we got our very light gray
background color
and we need to figure out how to make
this
image going all the way to the right
side
so i wonder if it would make sense to
make this position absolute on desktop
because if it's positioned absolutely i
can kind of position it and make it like
right zero or whatever
oh gosh got rid of the height right
100 will that fix it no oh yeah width is
not working
that's not right also i think i need to
add the
container to have shin relative
there we go this is kind of a mess let
me think about this again
okay so this looks okay it's just the
image that's not really working for us
oh what if i do something like i know
i'm already storing the mock-ups in the
before element
but what if for desktop i put the
background
background image svg into the after
pseudo element
so then i can absolutely position that
but then the flex styles don't get
messed up
let's try that what have i got to lose
right so
we have this before class here add the
after
it's actually going to look quite
similar to the before so i might just
copy this
and then just change the actual image
so i think since i'm going to move the
background image here i'm just going to
comment it out here you know to kind of
cover my
cover my butt in case i need to go back
to this so let's
try this again okay um we got two
background images
as now slowing the mobile so what i
actually need to do is
background image none okay so now we
just have the desktop thing
now the znx stuff is a little messed up
the reason the background image
svg is on top of the mockups is because
the background image is in the after
pseudo element which is coming after the
before
pseudo element and how css works is if
you don't sort of
designate explicitly what the znx is
it's going to
put elements later on on top of elements
before
i guess i could fix this relatively
easily by just switching the before and
after
so this will become four before
it will come after and then the order
doesn't really matter but
just for the sake of being more clear i
try to put the before
pseudo element before the after suitable
element now let's see that
okay so now the phones are on top which
is good so
let's think about this the background is
not
big enough you can see it's much bigger
in the design where it's like kind of
off the page
i guess part of the problem is the width
has to be bigger than
the width of the parent but what if we
make the width
bigger oh hey this is looking better
because it looks like the phones are
about the right size let's try one let's
just go for 150
width of 150 not too bad
just seems a lot taller the green parts
going
straight off the screen we can try to
fix that a little bit later
okay so we got this to be 150 width
now the problem with this is that looks
like it's actually starting
under the careers fit between blog and
career that's where the left edge of
this image is
and it's also going off so what if i do
left
of 20 and this is going off the screen
which seems to be
part of the design so just keep moving
it off screen the phones are a little
bit down so let's say top five percent
that's not what i want so i think i need
to do transform
translate why oh shoot
also background size is 93 let's try
contain
so that looks better because all the
phones are visible was it what 93
percent first
let's try to maybe match the size of the
design so it's going up all the way it's
getting cut off just above that 74
000 thing so 97
perhaps so it's actually looking pretty
okay let's move it a little bit to the
left
that looks pretty good it looks like
this needs to be down a little bit more
so let's translate it down i'm not
actually sure if translate
is gonna be the way to go for this
because it's getting cut off
so the problem is i want where this gets
cut off to like stick to the top
i think i'm going to uncheck the
transform because this looks pretty
close to the design right
you can see this is going right up to
that top nav bar so i think i will
maybe increase the size a little bit and
then i think i just need to make the
after pseudo element a little bit
smaller
let's just worry about the background
image first
i kind of just want to start over so
let's reload to refresh all the styles
okay so let's start with just the intro
desktop svg
the problem with this was it's not big
enough right so what i did was i
increased the width to 150
which looks good so let's put that in
the code
before we'll add a little break point
here include breakpoint
large width of 150 percent one style
saved
now the problem is is that it's not
going down all the way to
like the blue in the design is going all
the way down the bottom
and this is not weird
let me actually add some outlines to
both of these just
so you can see a little bit what i'm
doing
okay so now i can see a little bit
better hopefully
okay why did that not thick or an error
oh there's an error there is an error oh
no mix and name breakpoint okay i was
typing some wrong stuff in there
breakpoint up now this magenta border
should show up
there we go you know what i'm just going
to hide this
right now i can just focus on the
background thing okay so this needs to
move down
all the way down to the bottom of that
hero
let's just do 15.
um okay if on
big screens it's gonna see more i don't
want it to like
get cut off something like this
or at least you can see that bottom edge
okay see this is hard guys don't let
anyone tell you it's easy
let's just add a little more space
the green is actually getting cut off
whereas in the website it's
you know not going all the way up
i think i'm just not making it large
enough
now i need to move it a little bit okay
so zero percent 83
that actually looks pretty good it's
still a little bit
taller so it actually is getting
quite close which is great
that's this looks pretty close i'm going
to copy this and we'll add it to these
styles
no repeat is fine and then background
position and background size change
see this is looking closer and closer
now i need to just kind of position the
phones
a lot of times when we're coding and
building stuff we try to just do
everything at once like i was trying to
do like the background svg and also the
phone mock-up at the same time but
it's quicker in the long run for me to
just focus on one thing at a time
so what i did was i focused just on that
background svg got that and then now i
can work on positioning the phones
i think you'll be more successful doing
it that way because you
aren't splitting your attention between
two different things or three different
things trying to figure them all out at
once
much easier when you just separate
things out and just attack one problem
at a time
so now these phones actually look pretty
close
now of course it's not going all the way
down under here
into the next section so we do need to
figure that out let's just get this to a
hundred percent
all right let's do contain oh
let me think about this the reason that
this keeps getting cut off
i was doing background size 100 and then
i was trying to do like
top five percent or something to move it
down but i don't want this get cut off
right i think it's because
the height is always going to be the
same so what if i make the height
taller than the parent which is the case
right because you're looking at the
design
the phone starts at the top and it
extends beyond so it's like 100
plus a little more so let's try height
of 110
maybe maybe a little bit more than that
so you can see now things are moving
down which is good
i'm really just overhanging a little bit
it's down a little bit too much
bring that top thing back maybe negative
two
but it's not going up here so i wonder
if i need to increase the background
size
yeah so background size
let's just kind of guess here 120 maybe
so the width also needs to be greater
than the hero image
div because remember the hero image div
is limited by the flexbox
properties that's why it's only 637
whereas this one needs to be wider and
taller than the parent so let's
increase this as well because we're
increasing the width
the size of the background image is
increasing too so we can take that down
by
decreasing the background size just a
little bit of like
kind of finagle things around so let's
start trying to align this
leftmost phone near that puzzle piece
thing so we'll add a left property
start with zero percent and we'll kind
of increase it
and then we can see it going up maybe
there yeah maybe a little bit less it's
the 22
perhaps i think we need to move it up a
little bit because it looks like the
corner of this phone is just getting
into that green area
so we'll move it up maybe that much
it's pretty close i think and then let's
see how if this is
kind of the right look that we got here
so yeah overhang just a little bit
now of course we don't want this to go
all up into the header
i think actually we don't want the we
want the top to always be
zero i think this looks pretty good
we do want to move this up a little bit
right but i think we can maybe control
that
not with the element itself but with the
background position
because i said center bottom if i do
center is zero percent
and then i use that so then what this is
doing is it's adjusting the background
image
within that div so if it if the
background image goes over
it's not going to show that overlap
because it's just the background image
it's not the div itself
it can be kind of tricky the more time
you spend doing this kind of stuff the
more you'll sort of understand
how things work and how different
properties fit together and like what
they do
this looks pretty close background size
should be a little bit more
let's try 95 and then we'll kind of move
it down as we need to
i think i can actually erase this top
property because it's just
zero let's take this these properties oh
yeah and the width and height properties
too
make sure we copied that over and then
put them into our sas
file oh wait this is for
just desktop i don't want to delete the
mobile styles
there we go okay so we don't need this
image mockups because it's the same as
the mobile styles everything else
is changing um we don't even know repeat
let's um remove this border stuff
because we don't
don't want to be distracted by that now
this is looking pretty close to the
design i think
if we increase the width you can see
you know it is going to nicely
stay flush that right edge we have the
mobile design that looks
i think that looks pretty close to what
we had then for tablet it's looking a
little weird right so i think
one fix for that could be just to
increase the size of the hero for
for tablet hero image so min height is
17.5
which is 280 pixels if you want to know
how many pixels something is if it's
using
another unit like rams or ems you can
check in the computed that'll give you
the sort of resulting
pixel size so this one was min height of
280.
obviously that's not quite tall enough
for tablet so let's say
min min height of maybe 400 pixels
you don't want it to be too tall because
you do want the whole
hero to i think fit in the viewport when
you're loading it in a tablet
but maybe just a little bit shorter your
image
i have the background here
and then the mock-ups ooh this was not
an immediate query
loading the desktop image that's not
good the motherboard looks slightly
strange here
okay let's fix that first so in the
before sudo element i need to move this
into a media query
looks like i just put it in the default
styles let's think about this again
but i changed things where i load the
mockups in the after pseudo element
and then the background images in the
before suitable element for desktop
but the background image for mobile is
in the hero image element itself
so i could actually move all these
properties into desktop i think
so i don't need the width i do need the
height maybe i'll just comment things
out just
in case i need to bring it back
okay so this still looks good on desktop
and then on mobile
it's only loading the mobile background
because before we're loading like both
let's go back to this section and we
wanted to change that min height right
let's try 400 pixels and then i wanted
to try
background position maybe center top for
the mock-ups
it's in the after so background position
center up i feel like center bottom was
better we'll leave it center bottom and
then we're going to
make the min height 400 pixels and we
will convert that to rems
for medium break point
up medium
400 pixels divided by 16 is 25
rems for large is just height of 41.
so here's the thing on mobile here it is
on
tablet and here it is on desktop
and it takes a second to load that thing
like that i don't know if i'm happy with
this
it's too big i think so maybe for medium
we can do something like
background size is something like this
i see two percent so hero image after
background size is 52
for medium
medium background size 52
so we can remove this commented out
thing oh
what did i do um i might have put it in
the wrong property
oh the before suit element after suit
element is what i need
for the mock-ups move that down there
this should work now okay that looks
closer to what we had
that is okay
let's just tweak this tablet background
image again
so i think i want to make it background
position
bottom so let's try center bottom or
center
then at least it's sort of like closer
to like what the mobile thing was
center 60. so background position center
64.
hero image on medium
there we go okay i think this looks a
little better right
it is hard because i'd say 99 of the
time
if you're in any kind of design you know
work situation or whatever
the designer is usually only going to
give you a mobile design and then
desktop design which you can see it was
the case here with front-end mentor
so for tablet a lot of times it's kind
of on you to
figure out okay what combination of like
mobile styles and desktop styles am i
gonna do for mobile um for tablet i mean
this is tablet and this is phone
and then this is
all right now before we start any actual
coding we're of course going to look at
the design and figure out how we're
going to build this
so we're going to be building the
feature section which is this why choose
easy bank section under the hero
on desktop you can see that they're in
four columns and then they stack on
mobile to a single column
for tablet i'm guessing i might do a two
column layout
now for this section i think what i'm
going to do is build this
using flexbox now there's a lot of cases
in layouts where you can use either
flexbox or css grid
i do want to show you both so i think
what i'm going to do is build this top
section using flexbox
and then for the next section under it
the articles i'm going to use css grid
for that
in my opinion i think you could use
either flexbox or grid for
both of these sections and it would be
completely fine let's get started
writing the actual code
so if we go into our code editor we'll
go to our index.html
file and let me just minimize the hero
section since i don't need that anymore
and we'll create a new section tag and
we're going to name it
feature okay or maybe i'll say
features since there's multiple features
just to make it a little bit more clear
now the first thing we're going to add
is the text above the four
features it says why choose easy bank
with some subtitle and that one is
full width on desktop so it's kind of
the same for desktop and mobile
so let's add that here we'll give this
an h2 tag
and then we'll copy over the text why
choose easy bank
and under that i'm going to create a
paragraph tag and i will copy
the paragraph text over there okay
so then under the intro text is going to
be
the feature grid since we're using
flexbox the first thing we need to do is
we need to create the parent element the
parent flex element
so i'll say div and i'll give it a class
of feature
feature underscore underscore grid
and then in that parent flex element
i'll create some more divs so div class
feature maybe item so each feature is
going to have this
div feature item let's go back to the
design really quick each feature
has a icon image then it has a title
and then it has sort of a description so
i need to add markup for all those
things
the first thing i'll say is div class
feature
actually i don't think i need to type in
div i just say dot
feature underscore underscore let's say
icon then we'll say
feature underscore underscore title
and then feature description
there we go so now we can add
the different icons that we need for the
icons and then the text
as well so for the icon let's see what
we got in our images folder so these are
the
image files from front end mentor that
we are adding into our project
so i'm guessing it's one of these icon
api
etc in our code we can say
image source and then add the
source as the svg file let's copy in our
text as well so what i'm doing here is
i'm just building
the first feature block just by itself
i'm not copying this
three times that i have all four the
reason for that is i don't want to
duplicate it until i know exactly
the correct markup and styles that i'm
going to use so i'm just using this
first one as kind of the first test case
let's see how that looks and i'm really
just seeing to make sure the icon image
is loading correctly which it is i
haven't added any other styles so it
doesn't really look like much right now
so let's go back into our code editor
and i think this markup should be okay
but let's start adding these styles
so in our app folder in our scss
subfolder i'm probably going to create a
new sas file
called features or feature i haven't
decided which one i want yet
create new file underscore feature i'll
just say feature
and i'm going to move it over to the
right so we can see everything
yeah so i'll do features as the section
tag and then for the feature grid itself
we'll just use the feature
name so feature
so i'm going to add underscore
underscore grid item
icon title and
description and this is using the bem or
block element modifier
approach to writing your sas styles i
personally really like it just because
it keeps everything in a compact file
with just the styles related
to these feature blocks the first thing
we wanted to do was
create a style for the feature grid to
use flexbox
let's go back to the design we do need
flexbox on desktop to make those four
columns for the features but on mobile
everything is
just in one column so this doesn't
actually need to use flexbox
i'm only going to turn on flexbox for
desktop so i'm going to use that media
query
breakpoint mixin
breakpoint up large and then i will turn
on flexbox with display
flex we're probably going to be
adding some styles to the feature item
for flex as well
so kind of get that started here and
let's just start out saying flex of
one all four of these feature items will
be on the same row
i'm guessing this markup is probably
fine so i'm going to take this
and just duplicate it
and that's using the ctrl d shortcut
so i'm going to save this and i know
it's all the same item right now but i
just want to make sure the styles look
okay
okay looks like flexbox is not working
for some reason
and let's go back and see what happened
so we have the correct rules
but actually i didn't include the
feature sas file
in our main sas file so
it's always important to remember that
now let's look at the browser again
okay things are next to each other which
is good i just want to kind of add some
spacing so we don't get distracted by
those other the other text underneath
let's go back into our section tag
and i'm going to add some of those
container classes that we created last
time to add
padding this container container p-a-l-l
for padding all should help and i'll put
it in the
features section tag there we go so it's
a little bit better
and this is one benefit of using these
utility classes like the container class
and container padding
classes that i created because instead
of having to
manually write styles saying padding top
you know 2.25 rems etc i can simply
create the utility class and then i can
use it in any html element that i want
and it'll automatically take the styles
so it's good because it's easier when
you're creating new markup
also you don't have to write duplicate
styles because i know these are all
taking the same
the same padding and of course we'll
probably tweak this a bit later on but
right now we're just trying to get the
basics down
one thing that we need to remember with
flexbox is that
flexbox does not automatically include
gap spacing between
flex child elements unlike css grid we
have a gap property
it's not included at least not right now
i think firefox is working on this
property but it's not universally used
even though i'm using firefox in my
browser i'm going to
manually add spacing using probably the
margin property for these flex
child items let's look at the design
again and sort of think about
what we want to do we need to add some
space between
these flex items and it's hard to tell
exactly how much the space is because
the text is left aligned so you're not
always going to have consistent spacing
between
items but we can make an educated guess
here right i'm using this little
rectangle that i created in adobe xd
using the the rectangle tool up here and
it's just an easy way for me to kind of
eyeball
how much space and how big things are
this you know the space is going to be
at least this
much maybe more it says 29. in this case
it's 46. i think we're gonna stick with
the 29 so what i need to do is i need to
add
spacing between the flex items now you
might think
okay well the easiest way to do this is
to simply add spacing i could add a
margin right so that it would be
between each of these items right and
that would look fine on desktop but what
happens when we're going to tablet
and earlier i said i want for tablet to
be two columns in that case
if there's space between each item when
you stack them two
and then two underneath the second item
in that flex
row is going to have extra spacing on
the right so it won't look very good so
we need to figure out what we want to do
about that so it doesn't look weird on
tablet when you have
less than two flex items in a row now we
could handle this a couple ways
so one way would be in our styles we
could say
for the flex child items at a margin
right of 30 pixels or whatever but only
for desktop and then for tablet we could
say
for every other item it would have that
margin rights then you wouldn't have
that spacing
then you could do something like in each
feature item
you would add padding to the feature
item and then the content would
automatically have a certain amount of
spacing
so how that would look would be you want
to add spacing so there's space between
the items but instead of margin we're
going to add
padding because there's 30 pixels of
width between items
you'd add half of that to the side
pattern for each item
each item is going to have padding to
make it more uniform of 15 pixels that
would ensure that you'd have 30 pixels
of space between each item i personally
like using the
padding method more just because there's
always going to be space
between each item no matter if it's
space between items next to each other
or
items above and below each other then
you don't need to worry as much about
media queries
so let's do that now going into our
feature sas file
in the feature item we are going to say
padding
and of course we need our calculator and
it's
30 pixel of padding between items so we
need to divide that by 2
and say 15 pixels divided by 16 to get
ram so 0.9375
rims and i think i'm just going to add
padding all around the items just
because we know on tablet is going to be
two rows and then a mobile
they'll be stacked one under each other
so we're not going to put this
padding rule in a media query and then
also just for some additional
visibility we're going to add a little
border just for
testing right now let's see what we got
so now you can see we have our four flex
items
and they have a line between them and
there is some padding
so they're nicely spaced this looks
pretty good
since we did have the flex just for
desktop watch what happens when we
get below the desktop breakpoint they go
to one column and this is what we would
want on mobile
but for tablet we want them to be two
columns so how do we do that
well let's go back into our code editor
and we're going to start working with
the flex property more
now in the feature item selector we want
to add another
mix in for the tablet styles so include
breakpoint up medium
actually there's another thing we need
to do we need to make sure flexbox is
used
on tablet as well so we need to add that
medium
breakpoint turn on display flex for that
and then i guess we can turn this
off or not turn this off we can delete
that rather since we don't need to use
display flex just for desktop what this
mixin is saying is that it's going to
have display flex for medium widths and
up
that's hence the name breakpoint dash up
so going back into our feature item
selector
in the tablet styles we need to
tell each feature item to take up
basically half the width right so
instead of
the desktop where it's just fitting
everything into one row
and instead of the mobile styles where
everything is on its own row for tablet
we want each
item to take up half the row so we can
do that with the flex
property so the flex property is going
to
be 1 0 and then i'll say 50
now let me explain this the flex
property itself is actually a shorthand
property
and it has three different flex
properties that it includes
so the first one is flex grow second one
is flex shrink
and the last one is flex basis now flex
basis
means the default width that the item is
going to have
in our case we want the feature item to
take up half the width so we say flex
spaces is 50
now for flex grow what does that mean
well setting it to one
as opposed to zero means that it's
allowed to grow
in order to fill the space so that's why
for the large we set it to just flex one
and this is kind of a shorthand way of
saying
flex one zero and then i believe either
auto or zero percent
but you can just say flex one to make
the flex child item
fit the available width with as many of
the flex child items as
exist so if you want all the items to be
the same width and to be on the same row
you would say flex of 1. so in our case
what is happening here is that each
feature item is going to take up half
the width
and it's going to be allowed to grow to
fill up the space if it needs to
although this is not strictly necessary
so this should also work
even if we said flex grow of zero the
next one is flex shrink
this basically means if the item's
allowed to shrink less than the flex
basis in order to
fit on the row so let's just start off
with zero zero fifty percent
and i'm going to also need to turn on
wrapping and flexbox because by default
if you don't turn
wrapping on it's going to try to fit all
the child items in one row
so flex wrap
and set to wrap okay so now i think we
have the styles we need to
have the tablet styles look correct okay
so here's the page
let's see how it looks on tablet oh look
at that
so now it's taking up 50 starting from
the
medium break point then as we continue
decreasing it'll go to one column
for mobile so this general layout is
pretty set now it's kind of doing
everything we want to do in terms of the
number of columns
so i think this should be all set in
terms of flexbox stuff
now let's move on to making each of
these items have the correct icon as
well as the correct text
okay so going down here the next one is
simple budgeting
okay so we got our text down now we need
to make sure the icons are correct
the second one is simple budgeting let's
see the file names
on images icon budgeting icon budgeting
that's the name
[Music]
budgeting next section is fast
onboarding so
icon onboarding
then we got open api so it's probably
this one icon api
see how it looks on the website and we
have our different icons and the text
which is great
let's go back and style the text and
also fix
some of this spacing stuff here the
first thing we're going to do is we want
to make sure that the intro
text has the correct styles
so if we go up here it looks like the h2
tag
is going to be smaller than the hero
h1 tag so let's see let's kind of
estimate how big this text is
i'm going to say it's going to be about
37 maybe 36 pixels
let's start adding some global text
styles for the
h tags so a little descriptor there
so for h2 the font size was
36 pixels divided by 16
is 2.25 rims
and i believe that's just for desktop
because if we look at the design
the ychu's easy bank text looks smaller
on mobile so we're going to add some
styles for mobile as well
this is about 30. not too much different
but
you know different enough 1.875 rams
1.875 rams and then we'll add the font
size 2.25 rams
in our point let's say
just for large so we're going to tell
the tablet
[Music]
styles to use the oh oh i forgot again
break point dash
up there's a little error down there and
we also need to
look at the margin underneath so what
i'm kind of looking at here
is the two h2 tags that we're going to
need on the page so why choose easybank
title and the latest articles title
because they look like they're the same
size and if you look at the format of
the page they should be h2 tags
from an seo standpoint i'm going to
measure the space
under each of them and make sure it's
the same and if it is and we can just
add the same margin bottom
about 36 it looks like this is a little
bit more
it's going to be 55. honestly
i think that i might get a little bit
away from the design and
have them be the same amount of space
let me just see how much space i put
under the hero in that h1 tag
it's not a huge deal but i just want to
kind of be consistent with the spacing
if i can
and see what i've done already it looks
like here
the margin bottom is 1.5 grams which is
if we look on our layout tab
24 pixels so for whatever reason there's
more space
under the h2 tag than the h1 but that's
totally fine
you know this is just kind of how the
design is so i think i might
use the 36 spacing 36 pixel spacing for
both
h2 tags and it'll just be slightly
different from the design in this case
so 36 margin bottom
and since we know that the font size is
also 36 we'll just say 2.25
rams and then there's probably going to
be a slightly different
mobile margin bottom let's see what this
is here
about 25. so 25 divided by 16. it's
1.5625
1.5625 rims now let's see how this is
looking so far
okay so there's a lot of spacing i mean
i guess that's how it is
now we obviously need to make sure the
text looks correct as well
so it's pretty similar to the h1 styles
except that it is a different size
so let's copy some of the h1 styles over
oh where did i put those h1 styles i
wonder if i put it in the hero
sass file oh yeah hero text h1 i'm going
to move these
h1 styles from the hero sas file into
the globals just because
theoretically if there were other pages
on this website they would probably want
to use the same h1 styles as we have in
the hero
so let's do that so let's open up the
hero sas file that we were working with
last time
and find the h1 selector so i'm just
going to copy this entire thing here
save the hero and then we're going to
add the h1 styles up here
in the globals that way everything is
the same
now another thing we can do to make our
code a little bit more efficient is we
know
looking at the design that the h1 tag
and the h2 tags
are using the same font weight and
probably line height as well so i'm
going to copy all the styles from the
h1 tag that i think are going to be
reused in the h2 tag and maybe even the
h3 tag
into this compound selector for h1h2 and
h3
tags so we're going to take this color
is the same
we'll leave the margin bottom there
because it's different
but the text styles themselves we can
reuse them
so i think actually font size should
stay just in the h1 tag
there we go so now we know that h1 h2
and h3 tags we want to have the same
look and the only difference that
they're going to have from each other is
the font size and then the margin
bottoms
so this kind of just makes your styles a
bit more efficient let's go back to our
site
and now we can see that the h2 tag does
have the same
general look it's obviously a bit
smaller okay going back to our design
let's see what else we need to do let's
check out the body copy styles
and again it looks like we can reuse
some of the styles that we did last time
where the body copy looks the same
as in the hero section itself so
let's see where those styles came from
and where i saved them
so again it's hero text p line height
1.5 margin bottom is set
so the font size itself comes from the
body selector which is good it's the
default font size
what i think i can do is maybe assume
again that the
paragraph used in the hero is probably
going to be similar styles to paragraphs
used elsewhere
in the site so i'm going to copy those
styles over as well
into our globals so we'll put this here
under the
headline tag styles and we'll save the
hero one as well
and check back on the site looks pretty
similar i'm actually not sure if it
looked different from before but that's
okay
now let's see what we have compare it
back to the design
and see what differences there might be
now one thing i've noticed immediately
is that the text
the paragraph text in this section
doesn't go all the way across
it ends whereas right now it's going all
the way across
so i need to figure out how wide the
paragraph
is going to take and how i want to style
that
what i could do is i could add maybe a
max width
of this intro section it looks like it's
going a little bit more than half
because we can assume that the halfway
mark of the page is down here
and another trick that i use sometimes
is you click on the artboard in adobe xd
you go down here to the grid layout the
grid section if you check this box
it's going to superimpose columns and
this is really handy for designers
especially but it's also handy for
developers because you can
count how many columns need to be for
each section and i think this should be
yes
a 12 column layout and of course like
this is
superimposed on a jpeg of the actual
design so
i may have to mess with this a little
bit but i'm really just using this to
see where the halfway point is so the
halfway point is this
white stripe right down there and so it
looks like the paragraph is actually
going beyond that halfway mark but
doesn't seem to align
with anything else what i might do is
simply set this intro section to be 50
width or maybe 55 or 60 let's go back
into our index.html
and go into the intro section and i just
kind of put the h2 and paragraph tags
as direct children of the section tag so
what i might do
here is create a child div so class of
feature maybe intro
oops i'm running css styles intro and
then press
enter kind of hard to fight with the
muscle memory
okay there we go so now we have a
feature intro this new
selector that we're going to add into
our features sass file
so i usually try to order my
selectors in the same order as they
exist in the html markup
the feature intro comes before the
feature grid so we will add it
above the feature grid so feature intro
and i'm assuming that the 55 width
is only going to be for desktop and for
mobile it needs to go all the way across
so we'll add the break point
up large
and we'll say with 55
and in this case for tablet it'll go all
the way across but i think that's okay
we can always tweak it later with a
medium break point if we need to
but let's load the site and see how it
looks nice
let's see exactly how long how far
across that 55
goes so it goes about here kind of close
to the design right
we can also look at where the line break
is so the line break here is that
financial hub
financial hub's on the second line so we
could just maybe increase the percentage
so financial hub fits it looks like 60
might be more accurate
so we'll change this width property to
60
all right hey we're doing pretty good
here now the next thing we want to do
now that we've styled the intro section
is style the cards
first thing i'm going to look at is how
much spacing there's between the intro
and the cards themselves
okay so there's quite a bit of space
between the intro and the cards
themselves
now keeping in mind that we did add that
padding i'm just going to leave a little
extra space to kind of take up the space
of the padding i added
so it looks like it's about maybe 60
pixels tall
where do we want to add the spacing
let's go back to our site and check it
out
we could add it in the paragraph but
let's say the client wanted to add
another paragraph tag or multiple
paragraphs into this section
obviously this is a hypothetical client
since this is just a demo website but
this is kind of what happens in the real
world you know you want to try to write
your styles in a way that is
future proof as much as possible so you
need to consider you know what happens
if they want to add more copy or less
copy or
you know more feature items or less
feature items all these things could
change in the future because you know
these websites are supposed to be
representations of real companies and
things like that
in terms of the spacing i'm probably
going to add padding
bottom padding to the feature intro
section or maybe margin bottom
to add space between that and the grid
so it looks like there's some space
already
from the paragraph tag but we'll add
some margin bottom to feature intro
going to the feature intro the margin
bottom and i think i said it was 60
pixels
so divided by 16 3.75 rams
so margin bottom 3.75
rims see how that looks all right so now
there's more spacing which is
awesome an interesting thing i don't
know if you notice this but you can see
in the developer tools the margin bottom
is highlighted in yellow
and that's the 60 pixels you can see
that the paragraph also has margin
bottom
even though there's margin bottom in
both the paragraph and the feature intro
they don't combine together and like add
to be
you know whatever 2.25 rams plus 3.75
rams
so i think we can consider this intro
section actually
done one thing i want to check really
quickly is the mobile styles for that
looks like it is 36 pixels from mobile
between the intro and the grid okay it's
less it's actually
the same okay so it's still about 60
pixels of
space between intro and grid so what i'm
gonna do is move that margin
bottom property into the default styles
which are mobile styles in our case
so now if we look at the site it is the
same amount of space
at the bottom 60 pixels no matter what
your viewport is
all right the next thing we want to do
is we want to style these feature cards
so
going back to the design we can see that
the icons have some space under them and
we need to also style the text as well
so i'll start with the icon spacing and
the space between the icon and the text
is about 44
pixels go into our code and
the feature underscore underscore icon
is where we're going to be adding this
style rule and we want to say margin
bottom 44 divided by 16
is 2.75 rims
so now we got our space i also want to
make sure
the spacing is the same or see if the
spacing is the same so it looks like
there's a bit less spacing for mobile
let's say 30 pixels from mobile so again
we will add the default styles for
mobile
30 divided by 16 is 1.875
and then we'll add the 2.75 rams in
our in our
break point up large media query
there we go okay so we got our spacing
cool let me also double check and see if
the icon
image is the same or different looks
like they're the same just double check
that to be sure
about 74 and same for desktop so i think
we are good with this
they're staying the same between mobile
and desktop let me
actually add some spacing so that this
can kind of scroll it more so i'm not
blocking it with the image of myself i'm
just going to add some a min height to
our body selector at to the bottom here
we'll say min
height is maybe 200
viewport height see if that helps in
terms of the scrolling
yeah so now i can scroll down a little
bit just a tiny bit more
300. now i can position it in the
kind of a better place on the screen for
all of you now let's do the
feature block title looks like the
font style are similar to our headline
font styles
obviously it's a much smaller font size
let's say about 24 pixels
now going back to our code it was
feature underscore underscore title
so in our feature sas file we'll say
actually let's check the mobile styles
first
there's about 24 pixels big for the
desktop and it looks a bit smaller for
mobile
it's more like 20 so 20 for mobile 24
for desktop
so font size 20
it's 1.25 grams
and then we'll add our mix in for the
break point up
large font size is 24
divided by 16 is 1.5 grams
and we need to copy the headline styles
that we had used from the globals
so i'm just going to copy font weight
300 1.15
color dark blue and we'll add them over
there
for textiles i sort of follow this order
i do
font size first then font weight then
line height then color and then i'll do
line height under font size because
they're sort of related
let's check out our styles all right
looks pretty good
now let's add the space under the
feature title
so for desktop it's about 36 maybe 34.
and for mobile it is a little bit
smaller again
26. so let's say 24 and
34. this is going to be the featured
title selector we'll add a margin bottom
property
24 1.5 grams
and then the margin bottom for large
was 34 divided by 16 2.125
and checking back on the site looks good
next thing is to style the
paragraph the feature description styles
so it looks like
on mobile 15 let's say
16 just because and then
for desktop looks like it might be the
same actually for desktop and mobile
yeah i think they're actually the same
so 16 pixels for both
this is for the feature description so
font size and i know that 16 pixels is
one rim so
one rim it looks like we need more
line height because there's not enough
spacing between the lines fine height
let's say 1.5
perhaps a start font looks a little
smaller
on the design than in the website maybe
14 pixels
instead of 16. that seem a little closer
i think that's closer this will be 14
pixels and then 1.5 line height
so 14 divided by 16 is 0.875 rams
and then line height 1.5
there we go okay looks good
i think maybe we can take away the that
magenta border that we'd added
and then this should look pretty close
to how it should look on the design
okay one thing that i think i forgot is
i need to add that gray background to
this section
okay let's see what color is this in our
variables
so the very light gray was the hero
background maybe the
light grayish blue see if that's correct
so i'm going to add it to the let's see
i want to add it into the features
section i honestly might just rename
this to be feature singular so it
matches
you know the feature underscore
underscore classes as well
background color and we'll paste in the
light grayish blue does that seem right
that seems pretty close
now of course we need to add some more
spacing here because
yeah it's not quite enough
looks like it's about 110 on top
and then a little bit less on the bottom
90 on the bottom
let me go double check what i'd added to
that container class
that we'd created last time so i think i
said here we go padding top 2.25 rams
times 16 to get the pixels 36 pixels so
this is much
more spacing for this section i wonder
if i just hadn't added enough
yeah padding to this i might just try to
keep them all the same
around 90 or so and then i'll add more
for this top thing here
i wonder why i'd added only 36 pixels of
padding
i wonder if that's because of the mobile
style that i was looking at
so i think i'm going to do is just
increase the padding basically all
around for that container class
this will do 70 for mobile we'll do 96
for desktop and then we'll see if this
breaks anything
we're doing 70 for mobile so padding top
and bottom should be 4.375 grams
and we want that to be the same on the
bottom as well
and for now we'll leave the padding left
and right yeah so we'll just
any any case that we had padding top and
bottom
we're going to increase it to 4.375 rams
for mobile and then for desktop
so include break point up large
i'm going to say padding top
and that was 96 i think i said so 96
divided by 16
six rims this will be for both padding
top and padding bottom
this one just has padding tops we'll
delete that and this just has padding
bottom so we'll delete the padding top
okay so for now we'll leave padding left
and padding right
check out our website see if things look
better and if i broke anything
so you can see there is more spacing
here um it's good 70 on top and bottom
looks decent enough go to desktop but in
terms of spacing
the container the nav looks okay which
is good
and then here i need to make sure this
goes all the way across
but the top and bottom padding that
looks pretty good
let's fix this thing here basically i
need to make the container
p-a-l-l a child of the section itself
so that it doesn't get limited in width
so i'm going to create a new div call it
feature content perhaps
and then i'm going to move all the html
into
this child div then i will move the
container
out of here and into the feature content
and this will ensure that the
feature section itself will have that
light gray background and it won't be
limited
in terms of width it'll go all the way
to the left and to the right
you can see that's happening and then in
the feature content that's where
you get your max width set for the
content inside the light gray
so this looks pretty good go to the
design and do just an eyeball and see
if anything looks off or if this looks
pretty close
and this looks pretty close i'm pretty
happy with that i think there might be a
little too much spacing under here
under the feature title yeah that's too
much so it should be about 32 or so
how much space do we actually have here
34.
i think i need to just decrease this a
little bit so let's say
margin bottom 30 pixels
margin bottom 30 pixels still looks like
a little bit too much spacing yeah
that's a lot
less even though this is this does seem
correct
sometimes i just added spacing from the
the text afterwards so you can see here
there's a tiny little bit of spacing
until the text starts so this is
probably what i need to account for so
let's try maybe down to 20 even
maybe even a tiny bit more 22
maybe 24. i think that's close enough so
we'll change the feature title margin
bottom to 24 pixels
going back to our feature sas file
margin bottom
needs to be 24 1.5 rems
and then let's check it again for mobile
because that will also probably need to
be decreased
so it's a little bit less yeah i think
i'm just gonna have to try to eyeball it
again
margin bottom
start with maybe 20 pixels let's try it
with 16 pixels
we'll do 16 pixels for margin bottom on
mobiles
and 16 pixels is one ram that looks much
better
let's go back to desktop and then
compare it again to the design
okay spacing looks pretty good
and let's go to mobile see how that
looks
i guess we can use the emulator too okay
so on the mobile everything is
center aligned including the icon so
let's do that so
maybe in feature i'll say
text align center for the default mobile
styles and then
let's start this with medium since it's
two columns
for the features for medium so we want
we probably want those to be left
aligned
text align left it's not centered
um let's check back here hmm why is that
rule not working
there's no error in the sas and i cannot
see
oh wait oh no i did this again break
point up
okay now it should be good okay now yeah
text line left is
showing up so now i'm going back to
mobile
that looks good and then tablet width is
around here so this is going to be
you can see two columns everything's
left aligned
desktop it's four columns and
everything's left aligned
all right yeah this looks pretty good
looks
close to the design okay so i think we
can consider
the feature block to be complete
all right let's build out the latest
articles section now for the use before
we do any actual coding we're going to
look at the design which i have open
here in adobe xd
and let's go down to that article
section
you can see that it is four columns on
desktop and one column
on mobile and we'll probably do two
columns for tablet
now if you saw the previous video where
we built out this featured section
just above it it has basically the same
layout they're both four columns on
desktop one column on mobile
and i'd mentioned last time that while
we're going to build the features
section using flexbox
for the article section we're going to
use css grid so that's what we're going
to do today we're going to build out
this four column layout
using css grid as opposed to flexbox and
honestly i think that you could use
either flexbox or grid for both of these
sections
i don't think either one of them has a
super strong advantage over the
other so this is one of those cases
where you can just pick whichever you
are more comfortable with
all right so now that we have looked at
the design we can
just start getting all right so now that
we've looked
all right now that we've looked at the
design let's start getting into the code
so we're going to go into vs code our
code editor and if you've been following
along you might notice that my
color scheme are slightly different i've
been trying to tweak
this customization in bs code for a bit
and
hopefully when everything's done i will
be able to release it as
an actual theme so you can all download
it for free
but for now it's still a work in
progress
okay now to get started we are going to
look at the index.html and we're going
to add our html markup
so the first thing we're going to do is
similar to the other sections we're
going to add a section tag
so we'll say section and we'll give it a
class
of maybe articles i know that i
ended up making the section for the
feature section feature singular as
opposed to plural but
i'm going to try i think maybe a
slightly different approach for the
articles
now the section tag is going to be
what's going to be full width on desktop
inside the section tag we're going to
add a child element which has the
container class that we've been using
and if we look at the features section
again we see
there's a feature underscore underscore
content with some container classes
and we're going to use those same ones
down in the article section
so let's add that now so add a div
just by doing that dot for the class
shortcut and we'll say
article singular underscore underscore
let's say content and we'll
probably give it the same container
actually container
dot container dash dash p-a-l
which is the class for padding all
meaning
it'll add the padding all the way around
on each of the four
sides and in the article content i think
what we want to do
is um let's see what i did for the
previous thing
okay yes so we're using h2 tag for the
intro section and then we'll add
probably the same
article grid type of thing
so we'll say class article
actually let me look at the design
so there's actually no like intro
paragraph like the feature section so it
just has that h2
so i think i can get away with just
writing h2
and then we'll copy the text over
latest articles then under the h2
we'll add another div and we'll say
article
grid
and then in the article grid that's
going to be our css grid parent element
so then we'll add the child elements
we'll say article
i like to just say item for grid grid
items whether it's flexbox or css grid
so each each article is going to have a
wrapper of article
item now going back to the design again
we can see that in each article item
there's an image on top
and then there is some sort of text
content below that so you can kind of
break this
up into two different sections so what
i'm going to do
is say in the article item we'll say
article underscore underscore image
and then below that we'll do article
underscore underscore and maybe i'll say
text
and that's going to contain all the text
in the article
now the reason i'm going the reason i'm
wrapping all the text in one
div article text is because of this
padding all the way around
so if i didn't add the article text i
would have to basically add the
left and right padding to each
individual text element
and then i would have to add the top and
bottom padding or margin whichever one
you want to the first and last element
so i
i personally think in this case it's
just simpler to wrap all the text in one
div
element and then add a padding all the
way around
it's just a little bit less coding
involved
okay so we got the article image and
when you have an image you always have
to ask yourself do i want
the choosing and when you have an image
you always have to ask yourself
all right do i want to use an image tag
or do i want to use a background image
and one way you can sort of help figure
out which
approach is better is if we look at the
design
let's let's take this dollar image and
maybe i'll just delete this i don't
really need that rectangle
so if we look at the dollar image you
can see that it's the same image of
course
but the cropping is a little bit
different between desktop and mobile
so here it's more squarish and if you
look at the mobile
you can see that the right edge goes
just out a little bit farther it kind of
cuts off
on desktop right at the corner of that
one bill
the same goes for the left side you can
see that cuts off here
and it's a little bit longer on the left
side as well
so that kind of tells me that i probably
want to use a background image
for the image element that way you can
crop it to different sizes
and you're not going to you know adjust
the size of the image or
make it look kind of weird so in that
case
for the article image there's not going
to be any actual content
but i will add the background image
using
background image url
and then we need to add the url of
course of the image so if we go into
our images folder it's going to be one
of these
it's probably going to be one of these
image files here
so this one's going to be image currency
jpeg
so we'll add that in so we'll start off
with slash
images and then image dash
currency and i hope that
is that right yeah the images folder is
not in the app folder but it's in its
own
folder image image currency.jpg
okay then let's add the markup for the
text so if you look at the text item
there is first an author section then
there's a title of the blog post
then there's a either a description or a
summary
um you know you can call this anything
you want
so let's write the markup this is going
to be author title and then description
so i'll say article author
title
description
okay and then we'll just kind of copy
those over as well
there is an ellipsis at the end of that
description just because
it's a shortened blurb so we'll just
copy over that ellipsis symbol as well
okay now let me add a space here just to
kind of
differentiate the item from the grid
itself
there we go there we go
and let's see you know there's one more
thing that we probably want to do
and that is when you have a grid like
this if it's for blog posts or whatever
it's usually going to be a link and
there's no you know read more link
in the design so what i'm going to do is
make the entire
item a an anchor link and that's usually
i think the preferred way of doing it
because
even if you hover over the image you'd
like you'd like to be able to
click over to the blog post itself
anywhere you click on this section
so i think what i can do is article item
i'm going to make that an anchor link
and then we'll add href and of course
it's not going anywhere so we'll just
say pound
okay so i think we got all the markup
that we need
i'm just going to do the styles just for
this first article item just to make
sure everything's correct
then once everything's been kind of set
and we know that it's correct
then once we figure out all the styles
for this we can copy it
for the additional three items so
to start off with the styles in our scss
folder
i'm going to create a new file i'll call
it
article.scss and of course
since we created a new sas file we need
to import it so we'll say
import article
all right so we should be adding the
article sas file to the watch
now let me scoot this over to the other
side
so the first thing i want to do is
remember we made the section
tag have a class of articles so
i'll add some styles for that just in
case we need it
and then we'll add article
so we'll add content
grid
item so i'm just you know i'm just
copying all the classes i created in the
next html file
over to the sas file so
image text
uh oops author
title and description
all righty
and i may delete this if we don't end up
writing any styles for it but
i think we'll be okay all right going
back to the design
we need to figure out what the
background color of this is
and it's very faint but it seems like
the
blog posts themselves are white and then
this background is a very light gray
so it's probably the same as what we
had in the hero section so that's going
to be a style rule for the articles
section tag
so background color and if we look in
our variable sas file
i'm going to be this very light gray
color here
so we'll do that
and then see how that looks
there we go so here's what we got so far
we can see that
because i did make the article item an
anchor link it's
has that purple link text and it's
turning into the the hand when you hover
over it
but it does look like the background
color is correct so i think that is
just fine for now okay so the next thing
we want to do is let's get the css grid
stuff working
so for article grid
i want to
set let's just say
display grid for all widths even mobile
just to just to do it that way
okay now the first thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to
start writing the styles for css grid
now even though mobile is just one
column i think i'm still going to do
display grid for mobile
and then also tablet and desktop just to
see if that's
you know a good way of approaching this
so we'll turn on grid
with display grid now unlike flexbox if
you
write display grid just by itself with
no other styles
nothing is going to visibly happen
and that is because for grid you need to
not only set grid display grid but you
also need to start
creating your template this is one of
the core differences between flexbox and
grid
flexbox is more of a content first
approach so once you turn on flexbox
for the flex parent it's going to just
try to fit all the flex child items
on the same row by default for grid you
need to set the template meaning you
need to set up
the number and the size of the columns
and or rows
in in the layout so for our layout it's
a four column layout for desktop
two column tablet one column mobile so
since mobile is just one column we'll
say
grid template columns
and we just want one column so we'll say
one fr
and fr is a fractional unit it's kind of
a
general ratio unit um
used for css grid meaning it will take
up as much space as possible
and if there's more than one child item
in the column or the row it'll sort of
divide the space up
between those child items depending on
the number so 104 is kind of the default
like
you know auto kind of width so mobile
just has one column
now let's add the grid template for
tablet so we'll use our
mixin that we wrote breakpoint dash up
and for medium widths we're going to say
grid
and you can actually um abbreviate if
you just type in gtc
it has this really cool intellisense and
it'll automatically detect
so for tablet we want two columns so
we're going to use the repeat function
this is super handy for grid so repeat
takes two parameters the first one is
going to be how many columns you want to
use
we want two so you say two comma and
then again we'll say one fr
so this will basically create a layout
that has two columns and they will each
be the same
with one fractional unit
lastly we'll do desktop styles so break
point up
large and then again we'll say gtc
and instead of two we'll say four so
four comma one f
r so this is just your sort of
standard run-of-the-mill grid where you
have a multi-column layout
for different and the number of changes
based on your device width
so let's see what this looks like right
now okay
oh this is interesting so instead of
taking up the full width
you can see that this article is taking
up only part of the width
that's because we set
four columns in that grid template so if
we look at article grid
i'm using firefox and they have a really
helpful tool if you click on the layout
tab
and we expand grid so
it detects the that this is a grid item
because
you know has display grid so if i check
this box it's actually going to create
lines it'll number the different columns
and rows in the template that we made
so remember we just created a four
column layout in this grid thing
so it's showing us the four columns in
the grid template so if we added more
items
it would populate this grid so let's
actually do that now
i'm guessing the markup's probably okay
so we'll
take this we'll duplicate it one two
three times
save and go back to our
browser so now we can see that the four
columns are actually working which is
pretty cool
so let's let's see how this looks on
tablet so we'll reduce the width
and it went to two columns and then
one column for mobile so
yeah this is a pretty you know with just
a few rules we've already
sort of created our grid layout which is
pretty cool
so for css grid the approach that we
used
is a very sort of responsive design
approach meaning we're using media
queries
to change the grid template and change
the number of columns
there are some there is another approach
you can use with grid
that is more intrinsic design meaning
you don't have to use all these media
queries because there are some
built-in properties that can sort of
figure out
and adjust how the layout actually looks
depending on the width of your browser
so i'm going to show you one of those
now and then i'll explain why i actually
prefer this method
with the media queries so let us
let's just comment out everything except
display grid so control
k control c we'll comment that out in vs
code
and what you could do is for your grid
template columns
property we can use something called
autofit and then also another function
called min max and i'll explain what
each of those
is once we write out this rule
so if you remembered we for the desktop
oh wait i think i have an error here um
no it should be okay i think okay
so if you look down in the desktop rule
we had previously it said grid template
columns and then use the repeat function
we're going to do something similar here
so we're going to say repeat
but instead of writing an actual number
like
4 2 we're going to say auto
fit and this is a property that
sort of lets grid decide how many
columns are going to actually be
on the website which is pretty cool
right you don't have to say two or four
it'll sort of decide for you
and then for the width of each column
we're going to
use min max so instead of saying
you know i want this column to be 200
pixels wide or 1fr or 2frs
we can sort of again give the grid
itself
the basically the control over how wide
things will be
as well as how many columns are going to
be on the row
so minmax as the name kind of sounds you
give it a minimum and then you give it a
maximum width
in the parameters so the minimum width
we're going to say
let's go back to the design really quick
and
this square so this is about 200 pixels
wide
so we'll say that for the minimum we'll
say about 200 pixels
maybe a little wider let's say to 230
perhaps
and usually i should convert that to rem
so
let's do that open the calculator
and 230 divided by 16 is 14.375
so 14.375 rams
and then the maximum we'll say 1fr right
so
this will basically give the grid
column either a width of
you know 230 pixels 14 rems minimum or
it could be all the way up to 1fr so it
could theoretically
take up the entire space of the row and
this is actually all you need
so let's kind of see what that does to
our
grid in the browser so it looks the same
on desktop there's four items and
they're all in the same row
and each item is currently 265 pixels so
that is above that is between the min
min width of 230 pixels
and obviously one fr could be 100
percent let's see what happens when we
take the browser with and we slowly
reduce it
okay still four okay so now you can see
it broke to
three columns and then there's three
items on one row and then
one item by itself on the second row
we'll just kind of keep going here so
now it's
broken into two columns and then
for mobile it is one column
and this is actually really this is one
of the i think
this is one of the great parts of grid
where with simply one
rule in the in the grid parent grid
template columns using repeat auto fit
and min max it created this one column
two column three column up to four
column layout
so you know this is
pretty cool
now you know why did i mention that i'm
not
going to use this approach well even
though it is awesome that we can write
this rule
and create a multi-column layout without
using any media queries
i know that in real life if the design
has
four items and they want it in one row
for desktop
they may not be super happy when you
have a layout like this
where it looks uneven and let me show
you let me kind of highlight that by
hiding the grid lines so we'll just
pretend that there's lines around each
of them
let's do that uh particle item
border one pixel solid red
so around each of these items now is the
the
um throughout each of these items
there's a line now
so you know this looks a bit uneven
right
so this looks a little bit uneven i
think most people
if they want to show four items they're
not going to want it to look like this
it looks better when it's even and
there's just two two and two
and of course it's fine when it's on
mobile and it's just one column
but this in-between state is not
really desirable i would say and
unfortunately that's just kind of the
way that's kind of what happens when you
let grid
control you know the number of columns
using autofit
and then the width using the min max
function
so even though there's more rules
for the sake of you know kind of
maintaining control over that grid
i'm going to go back to the media query
thing
um and for auto fit
i don't know if i explained that fully
but
you go back to turning on the grid lines
and then
turning off the border
so for autofit what happens is it will
fit the items as well as it can in the
template
and the
the other option instead of autofit is
you could say auto
fill and they're very similar but not
quite the same
let's see if we can see the difference
here
it doesn't seem to be different
for us but let me just show you
um there's a really good article on css
tricks for auto fit
auto phil
okay yeah sarah sweden
i'm sure this great article comparing
what autofit and autofill look like
so in this example you can see autofill
will
create the template but it's not going
actually all the way across
whereas auto fit will kind of try to fit
the content to the row
and then if you go down a little bit
more i believe there's an animated
example here
so if you look at this the top one's
auto fill so you can see there's
actually a blank
column when you keep extending it out
whereas autofit
will you know fit the existing content
to
the row so that's one difference between
autofill and autofit
again you know maybe it's
you know not maybe it's best practice to
use this kind of
so that's autofill and autofit um again
going back to our own website i'm going
to go back to the media queries just
because i like having that extra layer
of control
but this is also an option and it can
definitely come in handy
um in in other circumstances
let's go back and we will delete this
and then we will uncomment control k
control u
there we go we'll save go back to our
site
and we're back here
there we go browser is a little slow
sometimes
so two columns on tablet and one column
on mobile
and it goes back to four columns for
desktop
so if that helps just kind of explaining
sort of the basic
this is a fairly basic css grid layout
i'm using the grid template columns
property
and then you can designate how many
columns you want with the repeat
function and
also how what size each of the columns
are
let's get started now actually styling
the content in the articles themselves
all right now let's start styling the
cards themselves
so we'll probably start with the image
up here
and then we'll move on to the text
elements
so using our little rectangle here see
that it's about
200 pixels tall so let's go into our
code editor
and add those styles in so this is going
to be for the
article image element so down here
article image we'll say height of 200
pixels
and we do need to use our calculator for
that so
200 divided by 16 is 12.5 rams
and then since these are also background
images
let's add some of those background
properties
so background size cover
so this will ensure that it will take up
the entire div
then background repeat and i pretty much
always
turn repeat off and then the other one
light and then
background position center center
to make sure it's centered i think those
should be good for now so let's check
the site and see how that looks sweet so
the images are
loading up um looks like we forgot to
add a gap
in our grid parent properties let's do
that
so if we go back up to the article grid
we'll add a gap
of maybe 20 pixels
and 20 divided by 16 and 1.25
grams so that looks pretty good
um let's actually compare that with the
design i think we got might be a little
bit more than that
just more like 30 pixels
so 30 divided by 16 is 1.875
okay and i don't know if you notice but
down here in the
terminal for some reason it always
throws an error when you start adding
the gap property i think there's just
maybe a bug in the live sas
extension but if we re-watch it
then everything's fine and there's no
errors
okay so that looks pretty good um
let's see what else do we need to do
here
did i do the background i think i did do
the background for the whole section
let's just turn off the lines for now
um okay so after the image we
have the text here and i'm going to make
that a white background color since
you can see in the design this is what
the text area has
so let's do that and let's also add some
padding
so let's see
here
looks like it's about 30 so let's see if
it's the same on the
bottom looks like it's a bit less on the
bottom but i might just make it 30
all the way around i don't see what the
horizontal padding is
looks like it's less it's about 25 on
the sides and then 30 on top and bottom
and let's see what we got on mobile as
well
looks like it might be a little bit more
on mobile
so the side padding on mobile is
30 i guess around 30.
and then let's see what the bottom
padding is
44 on the bottom
and then it looks like it's less on the
top
30. it looks like for i might just make
them all the same
30 all the way around well i guess on
mobile
should have a little bit more space on
the bottom
let's see if it's the same yeah it looks
like all these have much bigger
bottom padding that's fine we'll do
maybe 40.
so 40 on the bottom and then the other
sides will be 30 for mobile
and then on desktop i believe it was 30
on top and bottom
and then 25 on the sides is that right
okay around 30 for the top and then 20
yeah we'll do 25
okay
this is going to be the article item
element
we'll do the mobile padding first so
padding oh
caps lock padding so it's going to be
30 divided by 16 and 1.875 rems
and then we'll do the same thing for
everything except the bottom
and then the bottom is going to be i
think did i say 40 room
or 40 pixels 2.5 grams
there we go then we're going to do
for i guess tablet
medium and desktop we'll say
padding and i think we said
30 on top and bottom
and then 25 on the sides 25 divided by
16 1.5625
there we go okay let's see what we got
um
oh i know why the padding shouldn't be
on the article item it should be on the
article
text so just for the text that's okay
let's fix that move the padding down
there
there we go that's much better okay we
also need to add a background color to
the article text
color and i think white made a variable
for that
yeah okay there we go
so i mean it's a little hard to see
since it's a very light gray in the
background but
that is what the styles are and i
believe there's also a border radius
around the whole
card as you can see the the
corners are slightly rounded all the way
around so let's add a border radius
um it doesn't look like it's very round
so
i might do something like 5 pixels so 5
divided by 16
0.3125
and we'll just do it all the way around
and one thing you need to keep in mind
with border radius is that
sometimes in order for the border radius
to actually show up and sort of
cut those corners you need to add over
um
overflow yeah overflow hidden
so that'll make sure that the actual
rounded corners will show up
cool that looks pretty good
okay so let's do the text starting from
the top
just working our way down so the first
part of this card text is the
author section and this looks like it's
quite small
let's say yeah it's probably around
10 i would say 10 pixels tall
so let's do that so here we go
author font size it's going to be
10 divided by 16. 0.625
i'm assuming it's going to be the same
for both mobile and
tablet and desktop now let's move on to
the title
it looks like it's a darker gray and is
bigger
so about maybe 17 or 16.
let's do 17.
so font size 17 divided by 16
1.0625
and then for the description
looks like it's bigger than 10 pixels
since it's bigger than the author
but not too much it's about 13.
that's a bit small
13 divided by 16 is 0.8125
rims okay now let's see how that looks
looks pretty good now of course we do
need to do the colors right now since i
made the whole
article item and anchor tag it has that
purple link color
so we'll adjust those but size wise that
looks
fairly good we might need to tweak the
line height a little bit
but let's do those font colors so it
looks like the author
and the description are the regular gray
that
you know we saw kind of up here and the
title is the same
darker gray as the title up there
let's do that so since we have both
author and description the same color
what i might do to make it slightly more
efficient is in the
article text i'm going to add the color
property there
and then i will make the different
darker gray color for just the article
title
so if we go into our variables that sort
of medium gray is probably this grayish
blue
and then the darker gray is probably
this dark blue color
or the title
there we go okay
okay looking much closer so let's now
work with the
spacing so we need to add some space
between the elements and then we'll also
adjust the line height on that title
looks like it's a little bit too much
but first spacing
okay below the author is
16 pixels of spacing
that's one room so we'll add a margin
bottom of one rem to the author
then to the title there's some space
under that as well
um looks like it's a bit less but
honestly i'm just going to say 16 as
well
i think i'm being lazy
and then let's see what else we need to
do we need to adjust the line height of
the title
and also we'll check the line height of
the description as well
so right now seems like there's a little
too much line height right here
so let's try something like
line height and i usually like to put
the line height property under the font
size property since they're kind of
related
so 1.15 maybe
and i'm just kind of guessing here one
like a line height of one means it's the
same as the font size
1.15 means it's just just a little bit
taller than what the font size is
okay so that looks closer which is good
um
it seems pretty good maybe just tiny a
little bit more so maybe 1.2
so 1.2 okay
i think that's fairly close enough let's
check out the line height for the
description now
i think that's actually pretty close
yeah i think that's good enough
and it looks like the spacing that we
have between the elements is okay as
well
i feel like there's a bit less spacing
here so maybe we should make that
a little bit smaller so article title
go to the rules tab and right now
i think i had set a
margin bottom of 16 pixels or one rim
so let's adjust this so 16 pixels is a
little too
big so let's try 14
looks much closer on the design so maybe
10 pixels
looks like it might be less than that
actually
maybe eight pixels
okay let's do eight i feel like there's
less
spacing under the author as well i'll
just copy this over first margin volume
of 8 pixels
article title
8 divided by 16 is 0.5 grams
because i could have done the math
because 16 divided by 2 is 8 anyway
and the author well what happens if we
just do the same thing
0.5 rooms
it does look a bit better i think
there's still a little bit more space
under the author so we'll just tweak
that a bit so instead of eight pixels
let's say maybe 12
12 pixels
12 divided by 16.75 rams
okay so i think that looks alright
okay so i think our text is pretty good
actually
so now let's add the proper images and
copy for each of these
articles so in our next html file
we will adjust that just copy these all
over
i guess we can just cut it since we're
not don't really need to
keep it
this is already there
okay so let's do the images so in the
design it's the currency then it's like
a restaurant then
a plane with clouds and then confetti
so restaurant plane confetti
we look on our images folder image
restaurant oh i had the name right
restaurant and the second one was plain
and then confetti
all right let's see how this looks it
looks pretty good
so if we take it down comes two columns
and then one column on mobile
this is pretty good
not too shabby so one extra thing that
i'm going to add
is some nice little hover states and i
think i'm also going to add a box shadow
just to make the card
a little more separate from the
background so let's add those in now
so the box shadow i'm going to add to
the article item itself since i want to
go kind of all the way around
so article item say box shadow
and for box shadow it takes a bunch of
different parameters so let me just type
them in
first and then explain what they are
okay so in box shadow the first two
numbers are the position of the shadow
so the first
zero pixels will control the horizontal
position so i want it to be probably in
the center so i'll leave that as zero
pixels
the second zero pixels is the vertical
position
and usually for shadows it's better to
make it a little bit down from
the object itself so it seems more like
a real shadow
so we'll maybe adjust that to be three
pixels
and i'll convert these two rams once
we've kind of finalized everything
and the last number parameter is the
spread so
it's kind of how diffuse versus how like
hard
line of a shadow it is so i tend to
do at least 10 pixels maybe 12
pixels for the spread and we can of
course tweak that as we
see fit and then the last one is the
color of the shadow and for shadows
i usually like to use a semi um
transparent shadow so what i've done is
use rgba
0 0 0 which means black and then the
last
last number here is the alpha channel
meaning the opacity
and i've set that to 0.15 which means
basically 15
opacity so it's it's pretty semi it's
pretty transparent
um okay so let's
see how this looks
oh there we go so we got a nice shadow
here okay looks like we have some issues
down here where the white doesn't go all
the way down to the bottom so i think we
need to figure that out
um
so let's see what's going on here
article item goes all the way down there
article image and then article text so
it seems like
because the text on the first two is
shorter
than the last two because you can see
there's only four lines for the first
two
in the description but there's five
lines for the description for the last
two that's why they're taller
so one thing i could do to fix that
is maybe set the background color of
article item
white so now it's like
that so let me try moving the background
color to the article item instead of the
article text
see if that fixes the issue
let's do here
okay much better good
let's make sure everything looks okay
even when we're changing the width
okay
all right good
now the next thing we want to do is i'm
actually going to add a little hover
state so it just looks nice you know
when the these little i guess you can
call micro interactions so
the website kind of responds to the
different actions you take so i want
this to
change in some way when i hover over
each card
and one thing i do a lot is
scale it up slightly when you hover over
it
so let's try adding that and we'll do
that to the entire article item as well
so we'll add the hover selector and on
hover we want to transform
and we'll increase the size by using
scale and then
in the scale function we can set what we
want to scale to
scale of one means a hundred percent so
it won't change at all so we want to be
slightly more than 100
but not too much so maybe 1.05
so that would be 105 so we're only
increasing by five
percent so let's try that and see how it
looks
okay so it is just a bit larger and we
also need to add a transition so
smoother as well
so transition we'll just say all um
maybe 150 milliseconds and then ease
in out that controls this the smoothness
and speed of the animation let's try
this now
smooth like butter i like that
i'm pretty happy with that okay
so i think we can
actually consider this section done it
looks good on mobile
obviously on actual mobile there's no
real hover state but that's fine
tablet two columns
desktop four columns so yeah i think
that looks pretty good
all right so i think all right so i
think we can consider
this section complete
before we get into actually building the
footer i wanted to point out a mistake
i'd made in a previous video that i just
now noticed
and the issue that some of you may have
noticed already is that there's
horizontal scroll bars appearing and
this is caused
because the hero content the images that
we had
sort of made offset have forced
the container to be wider than the
viewport width and that's what is
causing these horizontal scroll bars
to display all the content so the way to
fix that is
in our code if we go down in our global
sas file to the body
selector we can add overflow x
hidden so what this is going to do is
it's going to
trim or cut off any extra content
outside the viewport width
so now let we go back to the website
there's no more horizontal scroll bars
which is good but we can still scroll
vertically because we only
did overflow x hidden not overflow
hidden which would
cut off anything extra and prevent you
from scrolling vertically or
horizontally so
this is one way to fix issues when you
do things like i did like moving things
kind of offset from the viewport or if
you have an off canvas menu
you might need to add overflow hidden to
some of the properties
so i hope this helps any of you who may
have noticed this if you're coding along
with me
and let's get back now to the rest of
our website all right so first things
first let's check out our design
so we have here the mobile design and
then the desktop design open in adobe xd
let's take a bit closer look at the
mobile version first so
in the mobile version we have all the
content stacked to one column looks like
everything's also centered
and the different parts of the footer
are the easy bank logo
there's some social media icon links
then we have some text links
a cta button and then at the bottom the
copyright info
for the desktop version if we go over to
that it has the same content however
instead of just being in one column
the content is split out into four
columns so the first column is going to
have a logo and social media
then we have two columns of the text
links and the last column
all the way on the right is the cta
button and the copyright info
all right so now how are we actually
going to build out this footer
well as in most things we can use
multiple different approaches
we could use flexbox if we wanted to i
think that would be a perfectly fine
solution to build out the footer i think
i'm going to use css grid
and the reason for that is i want to
show you all
different ways that you can use you know
flexbox css grid to do layouts
and we did use grid last time with the
articles section
but for the footer i'm going to try to
use a
feature of css grid called grid template
areas and it's a really
cool feature it is a little weird with
the syntax until you get used to it but
i promise
it'll end up being more intuitive as you
get along into it
so how grid template areas works is you
still sort of designate the template
meaning the
rows and columns in your grid layout but
you can use
named areas for each of the different
areas in your layout
and you can use those names to assign
where in the grid
you want those areas to take up but
first let's just get the basic styles in
place
and i'm actually not even going to use
css grid for the mobile design because
everything is simply stacked in one
column and then centered
then when we do the desktop design we
will use css grid as well as the grid
template areas
but the first thing we want to do is we
want to create our html markup
so i do want to keep in mind what i
eventually want to be building for the
desktop version so
for example i can't just have you know
individual social media icons or
individual text links just
in the footer tag itself i'm probably
gonna have to group them together
so we can lay out them a bit more easily
when we do use grid later on
so for example um i would probably have
to group
the logo or i would have to group these
social media icons together
in one div same thing with these text
links i might
group them into two different groups and
then at the end
i could group the cta button with the
copyright info
we'll see more as we get into it but
we're sort of keeping that in mind as
we're building out
the layout even though we don't have to
use grid for mobile
let's go into our code editor vs code
and in our index.html file i'm going to
start creating the markup
okay so i'm going to put everything in a
footer tag so
footer and i also need to create
actually a new sas file so let's go into
our app folder
scss subfolder i'll create a new sas
file called
underscore footer.scss
so that's open and then of course since
we create a new sas file we need to add
it
in the main sas file so import
footer save that and looks like
yeah our live sas is working so we'll
just close this up
and then i'm going to just move the
footer over to the right side so we can
see both
index.html as well as our styles so in
our footer tag we're going to
start adding the different content that
we need so the first thing was the logo
so the logo is usually going to be a
link so
i'll say anchor link i'm just going to
make the href a
pound and in the link it's actually an
image because it's just loading that
logo image
so we'll add the image tag
and we'll say source is images
and let's see it's a logo probably this
logo svg
so that's going to be the logo and i
guess we'll give it we'll start giving
things a class as well
um so first thing i'm going to do is
give the footer tag a class of footer
i know that seems kind of redundant but
in our sas file over here
it makes it easier to sort of follow the
bem or block element modifier
approach because the class of footer
will be
sort of the root and then everything
else comes from that so for example
for the logo we're going to give it a
class of footer underscore underscore
logo so then the same thing in the sas
file will follow that pattern
underscore underscore logo and the
ampersand again just means that it
inherits the root which is footer
okay let's go on to the next section so
under the footer was
i believe some social media links so
we'll create a div
called footer i'll just say social
so in this div we need to add all of our
social media links so since they're
links so again we'll add some more
link elements and i'll just again do a
pound for the href since
there's they don't actually exist and
then again each link is going to be i
believe an image so
image and the source should also be in
the images folder
and let's see which one was first
so in our design so it's facebook
youtube twitter pinterest instagram
so facebook's first so images
images and it looks like icon facebook
and then i'll give it an alt of facebook
so i'll do the same thing
for the other links and
i think there were six total yeah it's
not a five
so let's duplicate this by selecting it
and then pressing ctrl d
so there's five so i think the second
one
was youtube and then twitter
so youtube i'm guessing it's just called
yeah youtube then twitter
and then change to alt
i think pinterest was the next one
and the last one was
instagram
there we go
so we got the social links and then
let's kind of go look back at the design
so after the social links were the text
links so
as i mentioned earlier i'm going to
create two groups of text links
so let's say
footer links then i'll add maybe another
helper class
and we'll just say uh link maybe
column one there we go
and then we'll add our links
oops a
link and the links was
the text here so we'll just copy this
over
i think it was three per group
and then we'll duplicate this
so this will be footer links column two
and i'll just replace the text
[Music]
okay about his contact blog career
support privacy policy let's just double
check and make sure
yep that looks right okay and then
last one is going to be the cta and i'm
going to create one group to
enclose the cta as well as the copyright
so i'll say footer i'll just say cta
even though
the copyright's in there too and the
first thing will be the button so i'll
say
a class of button
and then the text was request invite
this is basically the same button that
we've had um earlier in the web
website and below that is going to be
the copyright info and i'm
i'm going to make a separate div for
that so footer
copyright
um easybank all rights reserved i may
have deleted that somehow
so i think the symbol is copy
easy bank
all rights reserved
okay so now we have our markup
and let's create the corresponding
styles in our sas file
and we're just going to kind of build
out the skeleton so we got footer logo
so the next thing is footer
social and in the social we do have some
links and images we'll just leave it
like this for now
and we'll add it as we need so next
thing is going to be footer links
and then footer links column one and
column two so
i'll just add those as well
okay then after that is footer cta
and then button we might need a button
so i'll just say
a button and then the last thing is
going to be the
footer copyright okay
so save that okay
looks good so
we're not going to have too much on our
website but let's just kind of see what
we have here
okay so we have a logo loading this may
actually be a problem because
this is the logo that we use up top with
the sort of dark color
but this is i believe
yeah so the footer has this dark blue
color
in the background let's just add that
now so we're going to have to i think
modify the svg
and i think we should be able to edit it
we'll create a new svg for the dark
um for the white on dark and then we
should be able to
edit that manually so
footer we'll give it that background
color
of that dark blue and it should be in
the variable satisfied so
yeah dark blue and then i'll just say
color
white just to sort of give it a default
um
and maybe actually since everything is a
link
we also want to say a
color white just to make sure that all
the text links will get that white color
okay so let's see what we got now yes
you can see
with that logo it is
not visible so let's make the
new svg file because i think we only had
that one logo
image yeah just that one logo so we
opened the svg it's actually just
like text just so you can um the cool
thing about svg is that you can edit
colors so
you can see here these different colors
this is probably the
colors of the symbol in the back um
so the you know this sort of diagonal
stripes
but we need to edit the text i'm
guessing it's this thing pathfill
um and this is just the letters of easy
bank
i'm guessing so let's create a copy of
this logo svg file
and then i'm going to rename it rename
logo let's say dash dark because we're
going to use that on a dark background
so alt z to wrap the words
and i believe this is the path fill and
then we want to change that to white so
we'll say
f and we can't use sas variables in here
because it's just
it's an svg um it is not i can't use sas
stuff
okay so we'll change to logo dark in our
index.html file
um logo dark
let's see if that worked e there we go
and let's just double check it that does
seem right yeah that seems right it's
just white
okay let's add some padding to this so
it looks a bit better and i'm actually
going to just turn on the
responsive mode so we can see what it
actually looks like
so we want to add some padding on all
the sides and we also want to center
the text all the content let's see how
much padding we need
it's using my little rectangle that i
created
it's going to kind of estimate it's
about
maybe 40 pixels on top
and i'm guessing on bottom um
so about 40.
yeah that's close enough and then maybe
we'll just do
40 all the way around nothing's actually
nothing is actually reaching out
to that far but i think you know
we'll just keep it at 40 just to have
some padding all the way around
okay so in the footer itself we'll say
padding
and 40
40 divided by 16 2.5 rims
and again that's because to get from
pixels to rams you divide it by 16 which
is the
base font size by default and rams are
just a more accessible way
that you can size things because it
gives the user control if they
change the zoom in the browser or even
modify the base font size in their
browser
if you have measurements in rems it'll
sort of scale up or scale down with the
browser
as opposed to pixels it would stay
pixels no matter what so
just better to use rems as opposed to
pixels you can also use ems
um but i like rams
okay so now with the padding see we got
okay
good padding and text align center
looks good now we need to
start adding spacing so i just kind of
go from top to bottom so i want to add
spacing
under the logo and on
down
and again i'm just kind of estimating
here so it's about let's say 30
and then under the social okay so
we'll give 30 pixels of space under the
logo also under the social
and then i'm assuming under the text
links
a little bit less but we'll just say 30
for everything
just makes it easier
okay so one add footer logo
we'll say margin bottom
and we'll say 30. so 30 divided by 16
1.875
grams and i guess we'll just add that
margin bottom
to all the elements that wanted them so
footer social i believe needs it
and then only the second footer link so
footer links column two
we'll have margin bottom as well and
then i think
under the button so in footer cta under
the button we'll add
margin bottom there we go
okay um
margin is not taking under the
[Music]
logo why is that it's there um maybe it
needs to be display
block or oops don't want to do it for
footery footer logo
because footage is every single link
which is like pretty much everything in
the footer
so display block and the reason this
worked
is because before display block the
element i'm assuming
yeah anchor elements are displayed in
line by default which means that they
just kind of display
however the default flow would be
and you can't add things like margin and
stuff it just won't
take effect so you can say display block
um or display inline block display block
it'll take up 100 of the width that it
can
if i do display inline block it will
only take up the width
of the actual content so maybe
displaying like inline block
would be better for this so
footer logo
display inline block
okay looks good so it looks like they
were
the margin did work for the other
elements because those are divs and divs
by nature
they are by default display block
elements
now let me add some space between the
social icons as well
let's see how much space there is
um 15 or maybe 16. it's a lot of one ram
of
space using margin margin right
so okay so footer social which is this
section here
and then i'm going to add the space to
the anchor links
so again we probably need to do display
blocks the margin actually like takes
effect so display
inline block actually um because the
slave block can make them all 100 width
which is not what we want we want them
next to each other
explain line block margin right
one round oh
and i don't want to do it for the last
one so i think i could use
the not
last child so if it's not the last child
it'll have this margin right
okay and that looks like it worked let's
just double check
so margin and then they all have margin
and then the last one does not have a
margin which is great
i think i do want display inline block
for all of them
so we'll just do this
okay cool now the next thing
for the text links the text links are
they are each on their own row oh what i
could do
is i could create make footer social a
flex
parent let's try that so display
flex and then i do need to set flex
direction
to be columns that will be one under the
other instead of trying to fit them all
in the same row
so flex direction column
oh not for social i want that for uh
the links there we go
okay so now they're very nicely in one
column
and centered i think i actually need to
do
is add some alignment to the
flex parent so
usually to control horizontal stuff
that's justify content
because it's vertical align items should
control the width of the children so
let's say
align items and let's just say center
just to see what happens
okay so there we go so now we have
centered them all
and then it only makes the flex children
take up
the actual width of the content itself
so let's add that in
our style so align items center
item center this looks pretty good
and we also want to add some space
between the text links themselves yeah
let's just say 20 because there's
usually a tiny bit of space from just
like line height i wonder if i could
just use line height to make that space
let's
let's experiment again line height
1.5 oh so i do
two actually looks pretty good
increasing the line height makes it take
up a little bit more space which
results in there being space between the
links so then i don't have to do
i don't have to add a margin to add
space between them which is like sort of
nice
so that looks maybe a little bit more
line height 2.25
for footer links a and i don't
think this is actually necessary anymore
since i fixed it with the align item
center thing
yeah that seems good okay so i think
that this
is basically the basic
mobile styles let's move on to the
desktop styles
and in desktop the most important thing
we need to figure out right now
is what the grid template for css grid
is going to be
so i think initially i'd said we're
going to make this a four column layout
so the first column would be
logo plus social then we'd have two
columns of text links
and then the last column would be the
cta button and the copyright
now i think that i'm going to also make
it
two rows because i want the logo to be
on one row
and the social media icons will be on
the second row so that means the entire
template is going to be two rows and
four columns
and i think the easiest way to
demonstrate that is just to use
adobe xd and to sort of draw squares
around each of the cells so it's
a little bit easier for you but also for
me to see what the template's going to
be
and then i can write the code in the
scss file
so let's start with that now so we got
two rows for this first column and then
we'll just have the same
you know going all the way down so
that's the first column for text links
and the second column for text links and
you know this isn't super exact right
now so there
is going to be spaces between the cells
but for
just for illustrative purposes it's not
going to be you know exactly correct
so it's going to be something like this
where we have four columns and two rows
so this means that using the grid
template areas
this top one would be called logo and
then
this one would probably be called social
this one i'll just call
links one and then links to and then the
last one will just be cta
and we'll use those names to assign the
locations in the template to each of
these
content blocks all right so in our code
editor we need to figure out where we
want to
write the code for the footer layout for
css grid kind of like flexbox you have a
parent element and then you have the
child
grid elements so the parent element in
this case is going to be the actual
footer tag itself
and then each of these areas are going
to be
the child elements in the grid so the
first one would be logo
second one would be social then the
links one then links two
then the cta these are all direct
children of
the parent footer element so in our sas
file
we want to add display grid for i think
probably just desktop and up so we can
do that with
a breakpoint um our breakpoint mix in so
include breakpoint up
large and at this point we will add
display
grid so again this means that on mobile
and tablet
it's not going to have the grid layout
it's going to have that stacked one
column layout
and we'll we'll do the same thing for
the other properties as we add them
so display grid and then grid template
columns and we wanted four columns right
so
let's take a look at what we want the
widths to be for those columns
so it seems like these first three
columns are
probably roughly around the same width
and then the last column is going to be
wider i'd say maybe you know we can say
these first three columns would be 1fr
or fr meaning fractional unit and
then the last one would probably be
maybe 2fr maybe 3fr
uh i'm not really sure yet and that will
make that
that will make this last column either
twice or three times the width of the
first columns
so we'll just do 1fr1041fr and then 2fr
for the last one
and we can use the repeat function
so the first three columns are one at
far each so we can just say repeat 3
comma 1fr
for the first three columns and then the
last column will be 2fr
then we want to add two rows so
i'll say grid template rows and
we want two rows probably the same
height for each so again we'll use
repeat
two comma one fr which means the
space each row will be given the same
amount of space
okay now the last thing is the grid
template areas
so this is a little bit um tricky
it just has a bit different syntax and i
know that when i sort of
started using grid template areas it was
a little bit confusing
but basically going back to our design
you write out the names of each of the
areas
sort of in the place where you want that
block to be in in the grid
so this one's going to be called logo
it's going to be going across
in the first row from column left to the
right it'll be logo
links one links two and then cta
and then the second row is going to be
social links one links to
cta so using the same name for two
different cells
it tells the browser that that area is
going to take up two cells so the first
one's going to be
logo so how this works is we just type
in logo
and it is in a string as you can see
here and the second column is
links one then links two and the last
one will be cta
so this is kind of the representation of
the first row
with each name taking up one column now
we have two rows in our template so
we're going to add a second one
in a string again and instead of logo
the social media icons will be the first
column
then links one links to and then cta
again
so this is our grid template now you
also need to in addition to creating
this
in the elements themselves and i guess i
should put this in a break point as well
so include break point up large
we tell it that the grid area name of
this element
is logo and this is part of the slightly
confusing thing but this does not need
to be in a string
one one place that i look to a lot when
i'm confused about grid or flexbox stuff
is css tricks
so a complete guide to grid and they
also have one for flexbox
so we're looking for grid areas
this is kind of telling you how the grid
temple areas work so you can see they
have
things in quotes and the actual element
you just have the name
and not in quotes again this grid area
property of logo
will tell the browser that the look the
footer logo element subscribes to the
logo
grid template area so we have to do the
same thing for each of these
so i'm actually just going to copy this
and then this is the footer social area
and that's going to be called social
and then for the links 1 we'll put it in
the column 1
and then we'll do the same thing for
column
2 which will be links 2. and the last
area will be
the cta and that's going to be the
entire footer cta element which contains
the button as well as the copyright info
so that's going to be
i think i just said cta these grid area
properties
they'll sort of match to what's in the
grid template areas all right so this
looks pretty good
obviously it's not completely accurate
at the moment but this is a really good
start
let's turn on in the layout tab the grid
inspector
so i want the footer to be highlighted
this is a super helpful
tool if you are working with flexboxer
grid firefox has these
special flexbox and grid inspectors and
it
just tells you a visual representation
of what you have
we actually have not only the lines to
designate the rows and columns
but it's also telling you the names of
the grid areas that we just created
it says logo social links one links one
links two links to
and then cta and it also tells us that
with this dotted line
it's sort of telling you that the area
is taking up those two cells whereas for
the logo and social there's a solid line
between them indicating that they're
separate
i think that let me just uncheck the
display area names
so you can see a little bit better but
we need to
kind of align these correctly right so
let's work on the horizontal alignment
first and i think we want the logo and
the social icons to be aligned
to the left you can control alignment in
two different ways one is
sort of global alignment when you set
properties on the grid parent
you can also set properties in each grid
child to just control the alignment of
that cell
so there's a lot of control you have
using css grid
and let's kind of figure out what we
want to do here
if you look at the design we do want the
logo and social icons to be
left aligned and we also want the text
links to be left aligned as well
and then the cta and the copyright are
right aligned so everything's kind of
like flush to the edge
so i think we could try using
justify content space between
is that doing anything it doesn't look
like it's doing anything this might be a
flexbox thing
let's go back into our handy css tricks
guide let's justify
items aligns grid items along the inline
row as opposed to
align items which aligns along the block
so let's try justify items start
so justify items start oh
there we go i think what i was doing was
justify content which
i use a lot in flexbox but i think that
just controls the child items as a whole
you justify content yeah so it's the the
total size of your grid
so that seems okay um i also want to i
think
maybe set text align left for desktop
because
it was centered due to the mobile styles
and then we can fix these as we go along
now why are these not
are these centered line item center
i have a few different things going on
here so i have the footer links
it's a flexbox parent let's turn off the
grid
look at the flexbox i had done a line
item center
and i actually want to align items
i believe start yeah start
because this in this flexbox parent it's
going vertically so
line items will do the cross axis
arrangement so i just need to remember
to set footer links
line items start for desktop and up
so footer links and then
for breakpoint up
large we're adding a line item start and
i'll make sure that
the links themselves are aligned to the
left
the other thing we wanted to do was for
the grid template
justify items
start let's go back to the
grid inspector now we can see that the
text links are aligned to the left the
logo and social are aligned to the left
as well
and then for the cta we want to align
that to the right
i think we can say um justify
items and oh this is not a grid thing so
i can't do that
i guess i could try text line right no
that's not right
oh it's because i did justify items to
the left
so i think for because this is an
individual this is the grid child item i
can't do justify items i have to
do justify self
because that applies to the individual
child itself so i think if i do
end there we go
so if i do text align right and justify
self end for the footer cta
desktop styles so under the breakpoint
area
okay so it looks pretty good for the
horizontal stuff right let's just double
check and compare that with the design
so yeah we got the logo and i social
media icons on the left these are line
left
this is aligned to the right and that
does seem like what we have
so now we need to figure out the
vertical alignment you know it looks
like things are a little bit all over
the place
so we go back to the design let's just
draw a box around the entire footer area
just to see how things kind of line up
with each other
looks like things are kind of extending
out to
the top and the bottom they're like
pretty much almost flush
so if we go back to the footer parent
itself
i think what controls the vertical
alignment
is align justify content and align
content
just control the grid in like the
greater parent
so if i want to control the alignment
inside the grid i have to use items so
align
items okay aligns grid items along the
block
axis so the values can be start and
center and stretch
so i think i want stretch so it goes all
the way to the top and the bottom so
we'll try that
didn't seem to do anything something
else is adding this extra
space i wonder i might have some margins
actually
so let's look at the links oh there is
margin in the social
so let's just cancel that out so margin
bottom zero
and then i guess logo also
there's a margin there okay i might just
need to go back and move all the margins
that i added from mobile into a
breakpoint
down media query because i only want it
to take effect
on mobile and tablet so let's see where
here we go margin bottom
so include break point down
some of this apply to tablet and down oh
medium i mean medium and down
and then we'll add the margin bottom
there let me just copy this media query
so same thing here
margin bottom here
and i think there was one yeah for the
button
okay now that we've removed the
margins from desktop let's see how the
site looks
did that help at all see the social
icons are still like really
they're too high i want them to be
flushed to the bottom
what happens if i do an align self for
footer social
i'll get rid of the height thing turn on
the line self to the end
does that seem right it seems a bit tall
in any case we want them to be on the
top and bottom anyway so
let me add a line self to footer social
for desktop
okay the text links themselves look okay
now i need to do this the aligning for
the cta
section so in the cta section we have
this
and then we have a copyright so i think
if i do
a line self miss stretch an option for
this
oh it is stretch not working this is
kind of annoying
okay i'm just kind of curious start
have an end i think i may need to
separate these out into different
cells so i can sort of align them the
same way i did with the logo and the
social
so footer cta i'll only have it have the
button
and i'll delete that extra div
and then do that so then footer cta is
in his own thing
twitter copyrights is is in its own
thing as well
so let's go back and first i'll have to
add
a grid area for the copyright since
that's a new thing
so include breakpoint up
large grid area and i'll call it copy
right then i'll need to add the
copyright name to the grid template
so before we had the ctn copyright in
one thing now we're going to have ct on
top and then copyright on the bottom
okay much better um so now we can sort
of try to
we'll add another rule for align
self end and then justify
self and
okay okay
that looks pretty good i do feel like
things are a little bit taller than they
should be
you know i wonder if the font size
should be smaller for the
for the text links you see that this
should be
15 or so pixels how big's the font size
right now
it is if we go to computed font size is
18
and where did that rule come from it's
just from the body font size okay
so for the footer links i need to set a
font size of 15
pixels so that should help with making
the content less tall
i'm guessing it's going to be the same
font size for mobile as well so
font size 15 pixels divided by 16 is
0.9375
rems all right let's give that a shot
okay looks shorter which is great
maybe the easy bank text itself needs to
be a bit smaller too
it's probably about the same 15 pixels
so we'll copy this property and add it
to the copyright as well
okay maybe there's just too much space
because i initially added all that space
using line height
so if i reduce line height it's still
a bit tall interesting
let's just say line height one just to
make it really short
oh you know what it is it's because i
set the row
i set the rows to be 1fr
which means the top row and the bottom
row have to be the same height
that's how i set it but obviously the
bottom row the social media icons
and the copyright doesn't need to be the
same height
as the top row and the top row looks
like it's getting its height because of
the button
which is making everything be too tall
let's
fix this row problem first and then
we'll figure out if we need to
decrease the line height for these
so instead of 1fr i think the
second row should be something
less where is it here grid template rows
so the first
top row should be 1fr if i do auto it'll
just
oh if i do auto it just sort of does
that
let's try that so in the parent we'll
change grid template rows to 1fr
and auto here we go so instead of
this repeat thing for the rows we'll
just do 1fr
and auto okay so this
is shorter now the line height is kind
of what's limiting it
so let's try one okay see now got really
short which is great
maybe 1.5 you know maybe i don't want to
use line heights that's kind of like
making it a static
distance what if instead in the footer
link since i know that is a
flexbox parent i could say
justify content space between and that
will sort of
auto stretch to fit that so i think
that's a much better way of doing that
at least for desktop we want the line
height for mobile because
we're not using grid for that so footer
links for
desktop here we go
i think i personally just do justify
stuff before the align properties
okay so this looks closer which is great
now i i'm guessing that this button
might be a little bit
tall i am kind of curious where this
height is coming from now
oh i still i forgot to take out the line
height okay that's my problem
so i'll just remove line height for the
footer links a
for desktop so i just want to use this
on tablet and mobile so i'll use my
break point down
and i know that i usually use the break
point up
meaning i use min width media queries
but i think in this case
because we're adding styles for mobile i
would prefer to
use the breakpoint down using max with
media queries
otherwise i would have to cancel out all
the margins and line heights for desktop
that looks a lot better so i think maybe
this button is now what's kind of making
it a bit
tall okay how big is this button oops
it is 46 pixels tall or so
and how big is it on the website okay so
it is
46. you know i'm not going to split
hairs here
i think this looks pretty okay so even
though it's taller than
it is on the design i think it's okay
and i just kind of added some space here
so i'm not blocking it with
a picture of myself for you all it's
kind of weird it even looks like there's
more space
in the design i think the logo and the
social media icons actually might be a
little bit too tall so
let's just tweak that and then we'll
sort of consider this complete
the logo should be 23 pixels tall
and about the same for the social icons
so let's see what we got
um 20 and the icons look like they're 25
okay so yeah they are a little bit big
the image itself says 20 which is good
and then for some reason the
thing is 25 the anchor link maybe i just
need to set a height
if i set a height of 20 pixels will that
help oh yeah it does
okay we'll just say hi 20 pixels for the
footer social a
social a here we go and i'm assuming the
same height will be for mobile as well
so
we don't need to use a media query for
that so 20
divided by 16 is 1.25
rems that seems all right
okay now that i look at this again i
think that there's a couple things i
need to do
the first one is i need to limit the
footer content so it doesn't go all the
way across
i think i forgot to add the container
class so let's do that first and then we
might need to
tweak some of the alignment okay so in
footer
i'm gonna have to add a container class
container
and i don't remember if i want to add
the
padding helper classes but let's just
move these into the footer
container and because originally
the footer tag itself was a grid parent
i'm going to have to move all the grid
properties into the footer container
so footer and then
we'll just put it here at the top
container
so we'll move all the grid stuff into
the container
element okay hopefully that'll work
let's take a look okay much better so
now we can see it's not going all the
way to the left and the right
things just seem cramped even though the
heights like so tall
is that button really the right height
yeah it's 46.
and you make the copyright text smaller
i think right now it is
15. i'm gonna make it i think 13.
it needs to be a lot smaller 13 divided
by 16.1
okay eight one two five not one eight
there we go okay i think the color was
darker too right it's not white it's
kind of a light gray
what color would that be maybe grayish
blue
so you know this is just kind of
tweaking trying to double check the
design and the site and just make sure
everything looks correct
yeah there's more space between the
button and the copyright
something is not right i wonder is it
including the padding that i added no
this is 70 oh okay so
it's 76. okay so it is adding the
padding so it's actually now it's
too short which is the same as like what
i was thinking it was so let's
increase that line height again to um
make it taller
line height 1.5 oh wait
wrong selector forgot a second
underscore there we go
maybe 1.75
2.25 2.25 line height is giving us the
correct height of about 100.
okay glad we figured that out so footer
links a
i knew something was off i just took me
a while to figure out where it actually
was
there you go footer links a
oh wait two point is that the same
oh my gosh it's the same freaking line
height
so let's remove this media query there
we go
okay this looks much closer to the
design
okay so now we've gotten the height
right i think we need to tweak
this like horizontal spacing
um there's it's too close here and
there's too much space i think
so yeah so it seems like there's more
space between
easy bank the logo and then the first
text link
let's see how do i want to do that i
guess i could maybe increase the width
of the first column so if we go into the
grid parent
instead of making all the columns the
same
[Music]
i could just try to tweak these a little
bit so
i'll probably leave the text links as
1fr
and so i'm just going to try this out in
the browser but what if i said 2fr
1fr 1fr and then 3fr
maybe 2far well maybe 3.
okay let's see how close that is to the
design
hey that's not bad
um there's a few things that look like
they're off so there's
just a tiny bit more space between these
i think i also forgot to add a grid
gap property so let's try that gap
of maybe one rim
two rims
let's try one rim
so that that gap property let me just
show you how it looks
so it's adding space of one rem or 16
pixels between
all the cells in the template so i think
that's probably good to keep
so i need to add gap of one ram and then
i need to change the template itself
will be 2fr 1fr105r3fr
okay so grid template columns
place this i know i could use repeat to
1fr but
i mean it's kind of the same at this
point if you're only repeating
if you're only repeating it once and
then what else that i wanted to add
oh yeah the gap of one i'll add the gap
under areas i guess
one rim okay that looks pretty
good let's compare with the design again
that looks fairly close and i'm actually
okay with like i have a little more
space
between social icons but i think that's
okay
all right now moment of truth let's see
how this looks on mobile
because we decrease once it hits that
break point for tablet
it goes to one column and it is centered
and stacked
then for mobile i'll just turn on the
emulator thing
that looks pretty good so i think we
have the basic styles down
now let's get to some sort of
let's kind of polish it up a little bit
there's a few things i usually try to
add
main thing is hover states because these
are all links and you want the style to
change
slightly when you hover over them so you
know what's going on
so for the socials
let's check the design oh here we go so
we did some if we hover it turns green
on the social icons as well as the text
links
and then the request invite has the same
thing where it like goes to white
so let's do those the social icons
that would be social icons the images
um they're svgs and we want to change
them from the white
to the green color now since i loaded
these svgs as image tags
i might actually change that because
what i want to do is
change the fill and the svg itself let
me show you what that looks like
so icon facebook if we look at that
so it tells you the fill is fff which is
white
and there is actually a way that you can
alter that in css
but only if you're loading the svg as an
svg tag
and not the image tag so i'm gonna have
to change this
so i'm gonna copy this
so we're actually just using inline svgs
at this point
and then i think can i just move the alt
no there's no alt for that that's
interesting
i'm just curious about this uh alt tag
for svgs
accessible it's purely decorative it
doesn't need alternate decks
i think we do because they're like
social icons
inside the svg add title oh must be the
first child of its parent element
it'll be used as a tool tip that's
helpful
okay so let's do that so
say the first child
um here so path
is the first child originally but now
we're adding titles and we'll add
facebook
that's pretty good and we'll have to do
the same thing for the other one
so youtube
copy that place the image
and then add the title
[Music]
youtube
so now let's load it up
everything's the same let's just double
check
yeah so it is actually loading the svgs
which is good
if we hover it tells us the title which
is great so
now to adjust the color
to adjust the hover we want to in the
svg alter the
path fill
and we can do that in css which is
pretty awesome
so if you go down to social a
so in the a tag it's going to be svg
path that's going to be the element
social
a cover
i could nest it under the a element but
okay
maybe i'll do that under the a
hover svg element and then the path
element
is going to have fill of the green color
lime green and then we also
want to add its transition so it's a
little bit more
nice looking hopefully this works
phil and then how fast we want to be
maybe 150 milliseconds
he's in out oh
hey very nice
cool so we were able to add the
transition and the hover
fill color for these social icons we
want to do the same thing for these
text um links as well that's going to be
in the footer links
a so footer links
a hover
color
lime green i think it was and then of
course we're doing the same thing so
transition color 150 milliseconds
ease in out oops
okay there we go
[Music]
nice and the last thing we want to do is
this button hover state
and you can see it's losing opacity when
you hover over it and that's because
when i first coded this button it was
just on a white background
so i could simply reduce the opacity and
make it sort of
look like there's a white overlay
obviously it doesn't work with a dark
background so i'm going to have to
build a semi-transparent white overlay
over this over the linear gradient color
so i think i can do that with a pseudo
element so let's just sort of
try so in our global sas file
going down to the button styles so right
now the opacity
thing i'm i'm just going to comment that
out because
it's not really working for us and i'm
going to have to add
a pseudo element so let's just try the
before
and content is blank so it shows up um
you have to have a content
property set for your before and after
elements
then i'll say background color
i just do background since it's
using a linear gradient um i think
background is actually linear grains
actually apply to the image
if i'm not mistaken background image oh
let me just see if that's correct really
quick
yeah so yeah background image
and unfortunately background image does
not transition nicely so
we'll we might have some issues when we
do this but
okay going back here so we're making an
overlay
um i'm going to have to position this
absolutely i think
because we want it to be on top of the
rest of the button
right zero and this is just to make it
go to
you know all the different edges and
because it's supposed to absolute i see
to make sure the parent is positioned
relative which it is
that's good and i'll make sure the
position absolute child will sort of
remain inside the parent which is
relative
then background um
color and because we want to eat rg
we want it to be rgba so it will be
semi-transparent
so white is 255 255
255. and transparency let's just say
0.25 we don't want to go
full white otherwise you won't be able
to read the text
okay now
let's just see
let's see how that looks and i'm not
it's not attached to hover state right
now i just kind of built it to sort of
test and see how it'll look
oh that looks it looks pretty close to
what we had before actually
um so let's set opacity so passing zero
it won't show up and then
it'll show up when we add when we get
rid of the opacity zero so
i'm going to use that for the hover
state this actually was a pretty
easy solution i thought it was going to
be a bit harder than that
so by default we'll set this opacity to
zero
and then on the hover state we'll set
opacity to one so we want to transition
that so it's nice and smooth
we use 150 milliseconds like the other
hover state speeds
then on hover um
hover on the parent we're going to make
the before element
opacity one
hey not bad
not too shabby okay so i think we got
our
hover states pretty good let's just
double check and make sure the top one
works too
oh yeah nice sweet
so let's just check one more time see
how this looks on tablet and mobile
good let's just use the emulator so it's
easier to see
so here's mobile looks pretty good
and then ipad i think that's okay
on tablet if you wanted to you could
also make this like maybe two columns on
tablet but
i'm just going to stick with the one
column because i think that's fine
and it's at the bottom anyway so it's
not like it's blocking it's like people
have to scroll past it
cool so i think we can actually consider
this whole web page
complete and that's it for building this
landing page template
if you made it all the way through
congratulations and let us know down in
the comments what you thought of this
video
and as always thanks for watching and
keep on coding